all right and we
are live the last word with lor condito
in igbotis
friday evening campfire what is going on
sir how are we doing
uh i'm doing good i've got a dog
recovering from surgery so
gonna be working with that one over the
evening and before we get going too far
i did want to say one thing to start
this off on a serious note because it
does need to be done
um i just want to read the very start of
the twab due to the events that happened
this week
so just let you guys aware before we get
into anything else um
they started the 12 well so i'm gonna
start with that we want to start this
swab off by speaking about the tragic
events from earlier this week
the violence against the asian american
community in atlanta wasn't an isolated
event
hate crimes against asian americans have
recently surged across major cities in
the u.s over the last year
everyone at bungie stands with the asian
community during this difficult time
and our hearts go out to the victims of
the senseless act of
act of violence and their families one
of our goals is to continue to build
communities
around our games where everyone feels
safe to be who they are and free to
build friendships without the fear
of hate or discrimination please join us
in making a donation
to aid efforts to help provide a
recovery um
and support and advocacy to those who
need to donate they've got a link it's
i'm readymovement.org
and it's just to help all the asian
american communities
that you can if you can support cool um
biggest thing i just want to say
humanity please just try and be decent
to each other that's that's all i'm
asking so
i wanted to stay out there sorry to
start it on a summer note but i didn't
feel
we should get into all the crazy that's
gonna come in the future without
addressing that one
so yeah respect respect definitely um
obviously we can't ignore what's going
on in real life so i'm actually glad you
you mentioned it because uh
this has been bothering me this week too
so thank you brother for
putting some levity you know there's a
reality in the world right now what's
going on is be decent to each other
yep do uh do on to others what you want
others to do on to you
actually emmanuel kant basically treat
others the way you want to be treated
there you go the golden rule brotherhood
and sisterhood
anyways try to lighten up a little bit
but uh
welcome to the last word episode 141
and it's glorious friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooting discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're gonna get right into it
i wanna introduce the lord who is not
only an awesome friend to the campfire
of the last word
but whose highly technical yet efficient
approach to the game of destiny
is easily reflected with his massive
triumph score
introducing one of the most dedicated
and highly decorated title members
within our destiny community
and a member of clan concerned the lord
of
it and mario kart and our favorite
reoccurring warlock
every 21 episodes
live from cali and making his return
into the campfire of the last word
mommy lord teasing teddy how we doing
sir
man i live for those interests i
i kid you not sometimes when i walk
around the lake around my
park near my house and you know i ponder
the mysteries of the universe and
and and everything i think about these
interests sometimes really it really
just hits me i'm serious i'm not kidding
like i know i'm kind of being
uh i'm kind of going out there but like
seriously like it's such a it's such a
nice feeling and uh
thank you for having me again this is
always it's always fun and i'm in a good
mood i'm i'm good i'm happy to talk
about that's saying right now yeah i'll
just you know chat with you guys
it's always a pleasure to be here with
you guys always a pleasure to have you
always in i
like i speak to e we always talk about
it like we love doing them you know
it's just one of those things you know
we got to celebrate the people in the
community who we appreciate you have
been
such a huge supporter a cool guy we've
met in person
you know what i mean you you family so
it's just like you got to get it you
still got to get the roach we got to put
the good food out the good cutlery you
know
it's like families in here so we gotta
cheat you right man we're good to have
you brother
that being said i've gotta interrupt oh
skodo
[Laughter]
i'd like to introduce another fine
gentleman to the campfire this year
this man was gaming as soon as he could
hold a controller
nintendo and playstation both had their
use but xbox is when the game
changed a die-hard halo fan honed his
skills of
his shooter skills and some elder
scrolls shaped him into a true
role player with those powers combined
destiny
was inevitable so let's welcome a man of
excellent taste
as all titans have a man who has been
podcasting
since the days of the word of the nerd
over 10 years ago
he will give you an insightly look into
your business marketing strategies
and we all know he'd rather be writing
but we all know he'd rather be writing
game reviews
hailing from mary park hall and a gator
alum
online personality on the rise an expert
on all things star wars
fast and furious wiki editor and true
lord of his realm
the one and the only man who actually
suited up for life
ty guy travis mcclunkey how are you
doing sir
what up nerds how are you doing how are
you going to crash the party
how are you doing it was it was a good
show i guess i'm out
yeah like teddy was it was
the last place that i will ever see if i
come over to your house
uh my room is very special but you're
only seeing like like a tenth of it so
what is that you got a workshop or
something over there yeah it's a bunch
of star wars legos i i own
i own every star wars lego from 98 to
2010 i think
man after my own heart oh yes
this is going to be i crazy i talked
about this with travis a little while
back i was like i knew teddy was coming
on and i've seen those two
talk on twitter i was like all right i
know you guys are gonna be friends
what's going on so then i was like do
you want to like surprise
drop into and he's like yes yes we got
to do this so
so screw destiny we're just talking
about star wars now right yes
monkey yeah the clunky's in the building
but also
uh so we got to talk uh since mcclung is
in the building we also have to talk
masterfact i'm prepping you
for our mass effect one versus two
debates sir
it's very hot and heavy man the
competition is fierce i need another
teddy what side of you of history are
you on sir i just need to ask you so
so i okay so i've never actually played
mass effect
so in high school in high school uh
which i graduated 2012 and mass effect 3
came out
um okay so so two two of my um two of my
friends were really really into it at
the time and we had this garage on my
friend's house that had like
seven tvs and every console and
everything uh whatever i'm a nerd so i
set it all up
and i watched them play through all the
mass effects
probably like five times so i'm
relatively aware of
like this i i get the general justin i
remember picking everything but oh but i
kind of know
uh mass effect one sucks just by
watching it like that game
and then two two i think was is the best
of the three and then three i just
i just know the ending was like terrible
but that's that's kind of all i got
i'll replay them when they release them
i don't like the universal like the lord
in the story so
no doubt no doubt alright we go we're
going we're gonna keep you right now
on the bench though cause they gonna try
to come at you and say well he didn't
play
and like i need the connoisseurs of the
connoisseur because
who we're going up against right now or
the side of mass effect was
pretty scary but i got my man i got my
man tiger travis we lit
i have a miss slo-mo i got some serious
historians some connoisseurs we got
random but we need one more because
we're a man down they they literally
just got acg right now
acg's on the side of mass effect 1 i
think it's just the gameplay honestly
like the gameplay is just so dated yes
that i think and they're fixing that
right
i think a new one so i think if they fix
that i think that game will be the best
of the three very very strong
possibility but we are talking about
it's in
original form well yeah throw that out
the window
uh well first off how did you get you
two
as well kind of meet each other i like
the eyebrows that how did you guys
meet up i'm gonna throw it to thai guy
first
since uh he didn't quite get a jump in
yet but yeah it's like how did you guys
get to
like meet how's it been going and you
know what do you guys usually talk about
in the off hours
yeah teddy and i so what's the pillow
talk like between you two the pillow
it's pretty intimate i don't kiss and
tell
we talk about the the galactic senate um
regulations that really shouldn't be a
thing
and let's just say
when we're pillow talking i'm all up in
him like palpatine in the senate you
know like
i'm like what is what i don't know
um
[Laughter]
betty actually teddy and i met during
covet i think
it was actually kind of fairly recently
but we had always been we've talked
about this a few times today we've
always been like in each other's circles
like we both do work for ign we've both
been to the same e3 events
apparently to the same e3 parties at the
ign parties at e3 and not
really interacted or met each other um
and then
uh we met when i
got i needed to get a new pc because i
was gonna play destiny on pc that was
like something i guess i got to do that
uh and also needed to uh to do reviews
on ign and
i had i haven't built my own pc in like
years so i'm just like way out of the
game and i didn't feel like
watching youtube video so destin hooked
me up with teddy and said hey this guy
builds a lot of the pcs for
ign if you don't want to build it he'll
build one for you and so i had him build
my pc
uh and then we just started playing
destiny together and then we found out
we both
are obsessed with star wars and it was
just you know
love at first sight is love the way it
worked
yeah but we've actually never met in
person so you guys haven't been petty in
person but we haven't
oh yeah
there's like a really high possibility
that we've like walked by each other
because like at the ign war room
you know you just you're interacting
with it's not that big so like
we've probably like i probably went to
go get food
at some point and you were also there
and we just didn't interact as my
assumption
yeah probably also you've been in the
ign office a ton of times and i worked
there for seven years so it's like
almost impossible
yeah yeah i was there every day yeah
so i want to ask both of you about clean
concerned
origins and you know because every time
i see any one of you guys like
you guys get it in man i just love
you guys always willing to help you know
because i love podcasts we need help at
times and we
we we need to get someone some carries
and these guys come through as always
love but um
what's the origins of how you guys get
involved with uh clan concern
uh so i joined around the time black
army was made it's actually
our good friend global reset um who's uh
um the founder of the clan and i think
there's a few other people in there and
uh he
sorry i'm getting like a couple messages
and it like really distracted me
so um he founded it and then it was
basically him trying to
um make his own clan because he'd been
playing with so many different people
and you're just like oh i'm just gonna
make it and uh
i'm probably leaving out some details
here but i i discovered them uh
after surely after leaving the igen clan
because no one was playing the gen clan
and we just kind of built it from there
right like like i had my friends join
and then you know some other people's
friends join it slowly just built up and
we have a wide variety of different
players that um
that all interact and we try to help
people on and and go through stuff um
and then do the end game stuff really
but uh we're pretty tight-knit and then
we got travis in there
when he came to pc uh he was looking for
some some people to play
nice yeah i uh before joining a
concerned i
managed my own clan for a number of
years ever since clans were a thing in
d1
uh my clan was called the intergalactic
gentleman
um
my clan was actually pretty great it was
xbox clan and we were like
pvp heavy always going flawless and
trials and going to lighthouse every
single weekend and
uh we were yeah we were great and then
d2 came out and people started falling
off the map after curse of osiris and
yeah the writing was on the wall and i
eventually gave the clan
to a friend of mine who uh was just
playing a lot
more on xbox than i was and then brian
malkowitz
convinced me to join concern but you
know
yeah of course yeah c team yeah so yeah
i don't rep it as much as they do
because i play on xbox where we have
zero clan members online in the roster
at all times because they're all on pc
uh but but once uh once cross play is
implemented that's gonna be a game
changer because it means i can actually
play with my clan members without having
to boot up my godforsaken pc and playing
in that trash heap that they call a
crucible playlist
um wow yeah tell us how you really feel
tell us how you feel
seem to have some struggles there on the
pc front i see
yeah well the teddy will tell you that
it is not a very fun place to be right
now we actually did trials together
teddy and i last weekend on xbox and it
was such a disabled
tweets and it's like we've disabled
trials again
we didn't even get to finish our ticket
teddy we got all the way seven
yeah but yeah last week was like the
epic
almost the epic of all loots this this
week's scene sounds pretty good too
this week play it tonight or it'll be
canceled tomorrow i know
i'm like literally i have already seen
it yeah yeah
feels like you got to jump in i wanted
to ask you guys though like what are
your guys thoughts on why something like
that even
happens like did you did they think they
had it fixed did they were like
hoping people didn't try the thing how
does something like that up nope never
mind like
how does that happen in 24 hours like
it's live it's not just wanted to get
you guys ticks
my guess is that they tried to solve the
problem by making it so you can't switch
characters and rejoin
and that just didn't work and so then
their new solution is just to
disable rejoin altogether which like i
think the solution they went with is
like a blunt instrument like this will
fix the problem but it'll also make the
playlist worse because rejoin is a
feature that should exist
and whatever they tried before to fix it
without using the blunt instrument i
think uh
just didn't fall through but i don't
know man like i haven't
i have no no experience designing or
coding games or anything like that all i
know is that
i work with uh coders all day like you
know
engineers that are doing computer
engineering and nothing ever
works in the live environment like you
plan it too it requires a ton of testing
so it kind of doesn't surprise me
what you think man um well so we know i
think from a tweet or something that uh
basically they
they disabled the ability to join on a
separate account
but people were then then they were like
okay we can just join on the same
account on a different character and i
think that's why i got disabled again
but on like a technical more simple yeah
it's even more simple i don't know
i i thought the first weekend people
were doing on the same account but turns
out they were doing it on two different
accounts
and um i know from other bugs and other
uh fixes they've done in the past that
what they sometimes do with something
that's kind of urgent like this they'll
sort of do like a
a band-aid fix and then later on when
they issue like an actual patch
not a hot fix like a patch they'll sort
of stealthily like actually fix it and
they don't disclose that to us because
we don't need to know that
as much as i would like to know but they
don't you know i'm one person
um but that's usually what happens so
i'm assuming that's what what
happened here is they kind of did like a
band-aid fix and then they would
um you know they fix it later and then
the account thing and the same character
obviously i'm not a programmer either
i have like a basic understanding of
programming but destiny's complex so
a little bit like i don't know a little
bit of spaghetti code
speaking of fixing i have to ask before
we get into it teddy uh
you not that long ago oh yes one
bit very should i say stressful
uh error that would that was plaguing
you for some time in reference to
triumph score
so please talk about that so the people
literally lost sleep over this
like like i i was so stressed about this
because it was like well you know aside
from the friend game which is
i think that's real right like i play
the game with my friends and that's part
of the enjoyment but like
they added a triumph score to the crown
of sorrows
i'm trying not to get like really angry
about this because i got really sick
so so so crown of crown of sorrow day
one triumph which you can only do for
the first 24 hours
for whatever reason when uh beyond light
came out they added 10
triumph score to it retroactively okay
now i did not complete crown
day one so i didn't have that triumph so
come beyond light i was like wait a
second i'm 10 score short what the
heck's going on here
so i'm doing the math and i figured it
out and i was like what is this
you know bs basically it's like what's
going on so then you know
then i found some like usually when
there's like this really odd
triumph bug or something like that like
there's like a couple reddit posts or
like
maybe like one kind of lesser known
streamers talking about it and that's
kind of it right and
yeah you know for them to know about
this stuff they're not going to see that
because
i'm sure they check a lot of reddit in a
lot of the forums and stuff but they're
not
they're not digging that far i think
they're not
yeah um so for about eight weeks
i would tweet politely at dmg and cosmo
with with you know screenshots and like
look what's going on
politely with screenshots and like very
detailed
present my powerpoint presentation about
right
uh you know why lulu's talking about it
and this streamer is talking about it
like
can you just acknowledge the bug like
can you just tell me that at least like
someone is looking at this and nothing
like they just they wouldn't say
anything so
in my head i had to assume like okay
they're not gonna fix it
because their track record typically for
this kind of stuff shows that they
they don't fix this stuff or it takes
like a year right they'll fix it in the
next expansion
and ever since um susan the drifter i've
achieved max transcore every season
so unfortunately last season i couldn't
i couldn't do it
because of the stupid trap now now to
their credit
yeah clearly they noticed me because
they fixed it and dmg
you know replied to the tweet and
whatnot but i was like
man eight weeks for you to not be able
to tell me
that this that someone's looking at this
like just just
can you just tell me please like i don't
yeah i don't even know when you're going
to fix it i don't i don't even care what
the solution is just
just tell me you're looking at it
you look like you want to ask teddy a
question
travis you want to say you look like you
you want to speak here
ivantas and i have talked about this off
the air but like
teddy and i are very alike but when it
comes to destiny we're the exact
opposite type of player he loves pve i
love pvp
he loves doing everything that destiny
tells you to do
and i literally it like i i don't i will
the amount of effort that i will give to
us
an activity i don't want to do in
destiny is it appalls
other destiny players i have not played
a single strike
or game of gambit this season i've not
played at all
people are like you gotta get bottom
dollar i'm like dude i
choose death first like i don't want to
play gambit and i will not play it
and so just hearing teddy talk about
this about how like how he's like
in class and bungie's the teacher and
they gave him like this homework
assignment
and he you know he turned in his test
and they gave him 99.9 percent
out of 100 and he's like no you you
know you got it wrong
it's just so nitpicky and hilarious to
me so yeah i do have a question for you
teddy
who hurt you is my first question
actually what happened to you as a kid
that made you feel
like you just have to have every tribe
it is psychotic behavior
so it is it is scary to me and
we're all worried about you okay so we
talked about you on fire team chat
very worried i'm i'm a completionist at
heart
just because my love of nintendo really
and nintendo teaches you at least in
every game it's like oh you gotta go get
everything and
as you know five-year-old teddy playing
uh super mario 64 or whatever it was
like
i gotta get all the stars like the game
wants me to get all the stars that's
what i'm supposed to do
yeah so i'm just an objective oriented
person so that's this is how i function
but uh
you actually brought something up funny
uh so in in sophomore year of high
school i had this chemistry teacher that
i absolutely hated i'm not gonna say her
name
but like i hated this teacher
she hated me and and so her way of
grading like basic assignments was you
either got a top stamp or
bottom stamp top stamp being indicative
of like you did basically everything
correct and then bottom stamp
being like oh you need to fix some stuff
there was no rhyme or anything
about it i love the detail i have an
identical memory
it's a person a gift so so
the stamp was not indicative of like
what you actually did was basically
whether she'd like to or not and and i
can prove this
because everyone in that class cheated
off each other like basically everyone
would copy everyone's homework
assignments
um so me and my friend
let's say he would turn his in and you
get a top stamp and then
i would turn mine and i get a bottom
stamp but it's literally the same
piece of paper with the same work
everything on it and
i think now that you brought bring up
this trauma thing it that just hit me
and i'm kind of like i think i think
that's what it was like
i was just not good enough for this
chemistry teacher and i don't like
chemistry
i'm really glad i could get this off my
chest because it's because
it's been talking like 10 years the last
word campfire therapy session
i just put down my warlock pull for him
to deal with them
screw that teacher out there somewhere
travis you gotta find a stamp and just
find some document you give him a bottom
stamp but later on
this is great i'm gonna i'm gonna reach
out to the teacher find the bottom stamp
and just she's probably she's probably
just gonna turn this stamp on the bottom
just an ass
right there
did i
what are we talking about now star wars
fascinating no we actually have to talk
about some destiny
just to go back to like the destiny
philosophy because i think this is like
so fascinating of like the different
types of players because i think
teddy is what like bungie wants every
single player to be like
like to just do everything and spend as
much time in the game as they can get
them teddy probably does it a little
faster than they want him to because
like
at the beginning of the season he's like
all right i got everyone i'm gonna go uh
work on something else and i'm like what
dude the dlc has been up for three days
how do you ever be trying
but like he does all the checklists
ibontis
and i think probably cog i think you
guys are like the middle ground like the
every guardian of like
you'll do some of it but you have a
limit like you're not gonna just
do like the most insane thing he's a
little bit more towards the teddy side
but he seems to be
more like less completiony than at least
teddy for sure
what he's in his bag he's he's calmed
down
i have moments of ups and downs yeah
it's like i had my solo
nightfall do in those days and i've done
my solo dungeons but also like
i don't rate as much that just hasn't
ever been my thing so there's pieces of
the game that i don't hit but i'm
unlike travis i also haven't just like
crossed things off the directory either
i dabble
i still dabble in places he has he's
done like you know
no go away i will not touch the gambit
it's it's more okay i'm so then i sit on
the opposite of teddy i am
bungie's worst nightmare i am the type
of person who like
if you don't give me like high
incentives
content that i like like i'm gone dude i
my xbox right now i've got my xbox on
right here my xbox has
1427 games installed right now
on my hard drives i've got 18 terabytes
of external hard drives
uh on my xbox i have so many games to
play
and like destiny is like dude i'm not
gonna do the same strike five times in a
row like i'm just not
i don't want the gun you can keep it
i'll still be good at crucible i don't
need it like
i'm fine dude like and they still got my
skills
exactly the thing that annoys me is like
there's no there's no activity
in destiny where you need like an adept
weapon to win like
right you can go through trials without
an adept weapon against somebody who has
an adept weapon you can beat a raid
without an adept weapon you can beat
grand master nightfall without an adept
weapon so like
why are people min-maxing and spending
hundreds of hours for these god rules
that they don't need like i could pull a
trash roll and just use it and it'll
it'll be fine it won't do as much damage
as teddy's over here with like his
abacus you know moving stuff back and
forth and trying to min max
i'm pretty sure teddy's the youngest one
here to be talking about an abacus so
we have calculators travis i know you're
older but there is a guy
i'm sorry i got my t-shirt ti 9000 over
here this is why my teacher gave me
bottom stamps my whole
shout out to the bottom camera oh my god
you guys i don't know how long this
episode's gonna be
just for everybody we just got past the
intro
yeah look at that like happy medium i
think between
teddy and travis because um in the
beginning there is
there is a little bit of completionist
aspect that i do see
but there's a part of me that has now
evolved into travis where i'm like
i'm not doing that right there's certain
things i'm like i'm not doing that but
i feel i'm well-rounded i'm still
feeling well i'm not all the way going
over the side i can't i can't ignore
certain things like i feel like if the
idol gives me the reward like if the
reward
is it will consume you if the world is
truly unique
i feel like you know what and i really
like the architect the archetype the
armor or
are you if i like a unique perk
combination i'm very
i'm very build-based everything about me
is a bill like i was playing with teddy
and i was just in awe
of i mean rest in peace to the homie on
chaos reach i know you're going through
it right now
but um you know like i was in awe of his
build because he's just got we playing
and he's like
he's just getting this super so he's
like the epitome of efficiency and i do
like that aspect of him where he'll find
these bills that are very effective like
especially like i don't find that the
internet finds
the initiatives embraces them you
embrace it you don't say it so for me
it's like like war mine sell stuff
you know when um uh god slayer warheads
came out i'm
i'm the guy like that fourth fifth
column in the armor
i'm looking at you know to see if i have
lucid blade like whatever i'm wearing
i'm trying to be
efficient and and and and practical with
some powerful build so i love that
aspect of it
and um it as he knows like raids for me
that keeps me in so whereas other people
lose interest
and they're like look i've done
everything i you know really nothing for
me to do
you know you've got your exotic quest
you know if there's a good
raid for that season and deep stone [ __ ]
really fits that for me
like shout out to back from dead he's in
there a couple of clan mates are in
there
like if they hit me up like hey carl you
know wait a minute we need one we got
five we need one
i'll stop what i'm doing jump in there
help him out that kind of thing
and um yeah that's because i'm kind of
in that book but the last part i'll say
to travis's point i have this rule now
i can't launch destiny first
if i do i will get nothing done on my
backlog
because there's always one more thing to
do in destin right
and like like travis i've got this whole
backlog of games that he always teases
me about like hi
how are you playing all these my backlog
is probably worse than yours
yeah like it's it's horrible so the good
thing about xbox is quick resume i can
go back and forth between a lot of games
but the reality is i have oh quick oh
bro
it's amazing shout out to you
y'all cause you're like a dragon bro you
got me i made it dude
i have every achievement in that game
and i do not regret my decision
it's amazing it's the most hilarious
thing about that oh it's the most
hilarious thing you've ever played
so anyway like for me the rule is if i
need to play another game i
must launch it first because if destiny
gets launched for it's this is selfish
it's in a relationship
it's like i got you you're not going
anywhere you're not talking to anyone
it's being you tonight it's that kind of
situation with this
so that that's the rule like that
doesn't sound like a healthcare
relationship it's not no
it's like here's the thing like i will
never begrudge anybody
for doing an activity in destiny and
grinding or whatever if they're having
fun
like if you have fun playing gambit and
you're like having fun on the grind of
bottom dollar like more power to you
so i don't play it shout out to your
voice i was playing with your boys dj
auris and them um
which one they're online no no i was
playing with them yesterday doing
exactly what you just said
yeah yeah they hit me up david hit me up
he's like yo we need i see you rocking
shout out to mj the ball shout out to
david um
and clint i've got the guy's name the
other guy um
yes mitch yeah yeah yeah it was us
they were like yo we can't grind bottom
dollar yo we haven't been unlucky i'm
like dude you're gonna get it watch
we played like four in a row and they
got like three bottom dollars it was a
great
but yeah like the so so for me it's like
if you're having fun in destiny
like go for it do the same strike 40
times brian malcolm it's like have fun
man like
he doesn't do that i can't possibly
understand how that's fun because
there's a thousand other games out there
that are you know
you could you could be spending your
time on but the thing about teddy is i
know he's not having fun
and he still plays it he's not having
fun for him
it is he's in a prison of destiny
most people are tourists to the destiny
universe he's a prisoner there
stockholm syndrome took over long ago
that that is what it is
sorry to call you out there but like it
is you're you're serving a life sentence
and nobody knows when it's gonna end
first of all is my audio is still
crackly because i didn't see that
message
sounds better now very good okay um so
what i will say is kind of defend myself
a little bit
the last like three seasons or so
basically since cove has started
um i've kind of basically just been like
i'm just gonna do the triumphs and i'm
not gonna worry so much about
getting all the weapons and getting all
like armor like if it drops
or if i can do it passively like the
umbrella system for example if i can do
that passively in the background then
sure
but like the bottom dollar grind and all
the other specific activity weapons like
i ain't doing that
that that's that is just a terrible
awful grind that i don't know how that's
okay
um and now that sun setting is not a
thing
uh my vault is safe so i
like i got everything like this this i
spent this week basically
uh re fixing all my armor because i
dismantled some stuff prior to sunset
and getting
um undone um i kind of cleaned my vault
out of stuff that i was like all right
this is never coming back because
they're not gonna undo this
you know this subset of weapons so uh
now that i'm kind of
you know peaked again it's like well now
just i play every week to get the
triumphs that i need to get that week
and uh that's kind of it and so actually
don't play as much as you think i play
uh though your vault is safe
for now
cabal invasion foreign and they blow up
that tower
yeah yeah but then you go back to the d1
vault and you get your gallon horn back
out and you're good to go
um i will say though in destiny 1 even
though i i did
almost everything in that game i wasn't
as like gun hoe about it i think with
destiny 2
um triumphs are a lot like achievements
and i used to be an achievement hunter
on xbox and so i think it's the same
the same drive that i have um what's
your game
oh it's like 140 000 but i was i was
like one of the first thousand people
that a hundred thousand
and then i just stopped because of
destiny uh that's pretty good i'll start
playing other stuff
be honest i play more nintendo stuff if
anything now but
yeah i mean that's yeah i i guess i mean
you're not wrong like we were our
different players so
uh you know if everyone can enjoy this
how much work is the is all the triumphs
every season how many hours do you play
just to get the triumphs
uh over like a whole season yeah yeah
um by the way can
sure i swear obs just died no
meanwhile we'll let uh we'll let teddy
get his abacus out
well i mean you know to calculate how
many hours it's
probably like to 300 hours maybe in a
season but you spread that out over
13 weeks so you know if you actually
want me to pull the abacus out and do
the math
he's working he's like that's like 23
hours a week he can hear you now
oh uh lbs died so oh
oh no it's
wait so it's none of this getting
recorded no we're well the audio will be
there there just will be a blank in the
middle for video so
oh oh interesting you got this little
anime characters here
you could uh you could always just like
splice the
the audio in to the video and just put
like up uh
a photo yeah i'll just do the last word
campfire animation while we go through
the recreation of a dramatization of
events and you just get actors to play
us
all right are we back you guys can hear
me it looks like everything's working
sweet
yep recordings are back going perfect
good nice nice no i was just gonna say
for
me at least in between all of these
extremities
it's been i think my relationship with
destiny has actually
gradually gotten more healthy um to lean
away from living just in that missing
out on
so many games that like i didn't finish
horizon zero done eventually i'm going
to come back and do that before horizon
west comes out or
yeah forbidden west uh and then just so
many more games like recently i just got
done playing orion the blind forest
like eight hours but i was like that
game is just fantastic
play the sequel it's so good that's on
my list now
i i did a poll on twitter so hellblade
is coming first
oh yeah he gotta play him so i've been
talking about a great game
so it's like exactly so i've had this
list of games
and more recently i've been working
through them it's like okay so jumped
and played inside
that was one night stream oh fantastic
stuff like
crazy creepy baby but yeah yeah if you
played limbo
yeah yep
so that and that's what i've tried to
because i was like
hard destiny and then creator and then
trying to focus on destiny
and now it's been nice to be i can still
i've kind of figured out the dancing act
which still you haven't
never enough time for but like the way
the seasons are now
is you know you can check in on the
tuesday if you're not going crazy
hardcore for the triumph score
you still can get most of the like
understanding of what's going on you can
still grind a little bit here and there
you can do some of the seasonal
challenges
i do like that you can get back to some
of the seasonal challenges later unless
it's a week of pvp and you miss the
certain thing in the start so
some of those are better some aren't but
i've also liked the point where it's
like
i'm just going to take like tuesday or
wednesday in the middle of the week play
something completely different
and i think that's honestly been
probably the most healthy thing
to balance out destiny's kind of
addiction but also go back so many that
i've missed so
that's kind of been my way to go through
it's like
i saw travis say this like who's playing
james it's like i'm not even high enough
i looked i'm like i'm 13 19. i'm six
points away and it's just like
there's two things that limit you one
your artifact score you have to get to
13 25.
period you have to get the plus 15 at a
minimum because your year score
only goes to 13 10. so you have to put
in x number of hours
however efficiently you do it i'm sure
some people are betting others just to
do a gm
but why as you said travis like is there
anything i
really really need in from gm's to go do
anything else in the game
besides gm's and i really like also like
why
why do you need to get to 1325 if
they're gonna cap your power
even if you get to 13.55 they're going
to cap you to 13.25 so
why i set it at 13.25 why can't it be
1310 why can't it be 1300
right if your power doesn't matter
anyway or maybe power just doesn't
matter and you make everybody
artificially the same power and the
enemies do the same amount of damage to
everyone like
if that's the way you're going to play
the game i don't i just i really am
we're probably going to talk about this
later because we were honestly i was
trying to lead into it now so you kind
of beat me to it but that's
i don't know when it comes to for both
you guys and teddy i definitely wanted
to pick your brain on this one
the power grind itself i haven't picked
your brain on in a minute but also now
we got the announcement in the state of
the game the power grind is only the
pinnacles coming next season
so if you already hit 1310 you go 13 10
to 13 20.
that's it if you weren't 1310 your
powerfuls last for about five minutes
and then you're right back at the the
pinnacle grind again
we've been through that before with
season of dawn i was curious just
because we've had a bunch of different
ideas on this show about where you can
go
i wanted you have the first take on
honestly just the power grind now with
gm's out and stuff like that
where are your thoughts on that and also
on gm's themselves we'll get to in a sec
yeah so i'm i'm pretty glad that they
basically reverted
the like 50 every season because i think
that was just absolutely pointless so so
let's let's flash back a little bit so
season of um
the black armory season came out and
they had this insane power grind that
you had to do just to participate in the
first forge
and i think they took that feedback to
heart and every season after that was
basically
okay you don't have to do this insane
power ground just to participate in the
thing
i guess season of opulence who could
maybe say that's an exception but the
raid came out six hours after the season
launched so that's kind of a weird
situation that's very weird yeah yeah
and then they tried the ten level thing
with season of the dawn which i
i personally prefer that now in like a
perfect world i would say there
shouldn't be any leveling
season to season it should just be
expansion but that's that's just what i
think
especially now that they've basically
gone this this route of like
the seasonal model or the seasonal
activity that you're doing each season
there's no like prep you need to do to
do it you just you just go into it
because of black army like montgomery is
the reason that that happens
uh presumably every every season
yeah i would just before they there's no
power grind and then uh
like the major expansion you know we get
200 but i think the number is also just
kind of meaningless now at this point
because we're in the thousands and like
it doesn't it doesn't matter right like
it it's just sort of this this thing
that it's like all right well
it's a new thing i got to go do this
season just to play the gms and
to your point travis like i think even
though i do gm's pretty regularly i i
don't
like the leveling is just kind of it's
pointless because you're capping me
anyway
so i'm curious to see how they handle it
going forward now because it's only a 10
level increase
um if they're still going to have you
know you got to hit max pinnacle plus
15 on the artifact to be able to
precipitate because for me i think
that's just a gatekeeping method
um since you're limiting the player's
power through contest mode which i'm
fine with i don't have a problem with
contest itself
then the actual uh difference
or the actual leveling to get to that
point is just it's just another hurdle
that more people have to overcome
and and there is investment in that
right like like what if you got you know
what if you're one character player
per week and you get insanely unlucky
with pinnacles for the first
what is it seven weeks you know yeah
right and and
you just you don't you don't you don't
have enough pinnacle power to get there
but you have the plus 15 on the artifact
and that at that point that's kind of
just like well you're not at the mercy
of rng
um and the deeper problem is targeted
targeted farming but that's
you know i'm not gonna get into that um
so yeah i i just
i don't know like gm's are some of the
best content especially this week like
devil's lair gm
it's pretty fun you you all three of you
put a bow on you put the trifecta of
bose on you got one of each you got
rainbow bows
um it's fun like it's i don't i don't
think it's that hard i i could see it
being
difficult for for some people but right
um i i think the
the beauty of gm's when it's a good
strike when it's not a bad strike
yeah is that what's happening it's a
good strike though it's it's it is a
good strike
it's a methodical thing that it's like a
mini raid like you and your team you
have to go unprepared you can't just
unless you're like one of those people
that solos it in which case you're
crazier than i am
so saw that today yeah so like you
it's a great activity and for the most
part gm's are rewarding we're always
going to want more and people are going
to complain but like
when they do the double rewards drops or
even just in general
you get a lot of loot out of it and so
unless the strike is just
absolutely terrible or there's some like
really cheesy mechanic like glassware or
something
typically your time is rewarded
adequately for the strike
so more people with participate is just
better like they
they've had this philosophy with destiny
2 um they've never publicly said this
but this is basically how
they design a lot of stuff which is they
don't want the rich to get richer which
is a big problem that destiny 1 had and
that's why a lot of the systems in d2
are the way they are
so essentially people can't constantly
keep getting more and more while the
the middle class let's say or the lower
class doesn't get as much
right um it is a problem that they've
they've mostly solved for and
for me it's frustrating because i want
you know i want to get that
extra point five percent on my thing but
as i was alluding to earlier like
to me that you wanna get that top stamp
yeah i don't care i already already got
the top stamp right like it does it
doesn't matter so
um yeah that's kind of my take on it
like at the leveling
i don't even know how you solve that
problem like i've thought about it and i
don't have a good solution other than
just don't make me level every season
do you so i've said the same thing
actually and my big
question is leveling is partly inherent
to destiny
now we've gone through destiny one so
it's also kind of eluded if you
really think about it like like i've
explained it to friends that don't play
destiny but have like a basic
understanding of destiny
and just look at their face when you
explain other things
it's absolutely ridiculous like it's
nuts um
yeah but yeah that's one of the the
weird things about because you think
about
you had crota's what the hell was the
first expansion
thank you and then obviously we had
you know the destiny one feel of like
chunk of
expansion it's like we're we had that
first
and we hated the drought but now that
we're constantly forced to play
it's like the idea of as you're saying
and i think i've said
this too is like i all you're saying is
like if it's the day before the season
ends
and then the day of the new season the
only thing that changed is you took my
work away
that's destiny's history they've
invalidated your progress
a lot yeah yeah but it's like but it
doesn't do
new stuff it's to go play the same thing
old stuff
and that's i think the biggest issue is
you say hey here's a grandmaster
you said the glassway what if the glass
was up next season okay well i did it
two seasons ago and you're telling me i
can't do it until i put
100 hours into this new season again and
but also it's like the things a lot of
people like seeing the number go up but
i wish there was other ways for
something to change as you said if the
number just goes up but it doesn't mean
anything anymore
i'd love to see contest mode of what it
was just like at the powerful cap
right you could do a grand master at 13
10
1300 this season 1310 next season if you
could do it
and it just you're still it's still
going to be like 13 25 instead of 1350
so there's still 25 above you you know
vandals one shot you all that stuff's
still the same
but as you said as soon as you hit the
powerful cap you can do them and also
it's the whole
six weeks later one thing about that and
i heard i could have been dcp
i can't remember i listened to too many
um
i think one of them just basically said
a lot of people start the season strong
and then they fall off like six seven
weeks later once they find if they're
not active players like
you got your catharians and stuff like
hey i'll play the new stuff and then
take a break and go do other things
well they're never even gonna be around
for grand master release because it's
halfway through a season every time
right so it's weird i've thought about
this a lot
you bought this because we talked about
it last time i was on your show and we
were like i don't understand the power
grind i don't get
like how do you fix this problem it was
just such a weird thing so i spent like
a couple hours thinking about it the
other day um
i think the purpose of a power grind
is to like help people
with a skill check and also to make you
feel more powerful and it's not doing
either of those things right now and i
think that
it kind of needs to be reworked to do
both right like
it in my opinion if they're going to
increase the power level by 10
every season they should give you
activities that you can enter at any
level but
they're a lot easier if you enter them
at the max level with the plus 10 that
they want you to grind for
and you have all season to do that and
you can get plus 10 but
if you'd rather not do that and you just
want to rely on skill and you don't need
the extra padding then you can stay at
your
you know 10 below level that's much
easier to get to and
still complete activities if you're like
the teddies of the world who are like
min maxing and doing all that stuff that
you need to do
um and then on the other side making you
feel more powerful is something that is
desperately missing in destiny
i think they need to create a formula
like
i don't know if any of you guys like
rpgs but uh like
there's you know fallout new vegas
versus fallout 3 the differing
philosophy where
i guess skyrim is a better example where
in one of them
everything levels with you right and
destiny
kind of you kind of never end up feeling
more powerful destiny is
is that now uh versus fallout new vegas
where
you could technically go straight to the
last level of the game and finish the
game in seven minutes like the
speedrunners did
on ign or but if you do that everyone at
that
that end area is gonna be like 50 levels
above you and they're just gonna just
knock your dick in the dirt right like
that sort of
like the i don't know
yeah that's a new one but yeah they're
just they're just gonna just destroy you
and i think that
destiny needs that kind of like
lethality where like it doesn't gate you
but it should
warn you like hey if you go to this area
if you try this activity you're
way below recommended but they should
let you attempt it and it should be
feasible to beat a grand master
nightfall
10 below and a little bit easier if you
do it
at the the current cap and then
there should be other activities i can
go back into and just destroy
i mean if i want that power fantasy if i
just want to like let off some steam
and like i know that i know they're
trying to keep the
the kind of destiny world contained but
there's just needs to be a sandbox
maybe there's maybe there's destiny 2
and then there's the destiny 2 vault and
they're separate games
separate apps you can open up and bring
your character to the vault just to do
old stuff and and wreck people and then
you go to the current game
where everything is balanced but there
needs to be some way to do that
um and i don't think they're they're
doing that right now and then to kind of
the
the grind you know i've i've been lucky
enough to talk to a lot of people work
at bungie and kind of get their feel on
like what the philosophy was
and i know that when they created
destiny 2 one of their main pillars that
they kept telling us when we're at the
on-site review event we were there for
like a week in a hotel
nothing to do but talk about and play
destiny right and
they they kept telling us like we want
to take the work out of playing destiny
we don't want these rituals where like
you feel like you
have to do everything every week and
it's kind of like a job
we don't think that that's fun and they
were speaking as
them like they were like me personally i
don't like that and yeah and i was
standing there with them like
me too dude like i for sure i'm one of
you like i don't want it to be a chore
and they tried it and i think that their
takeaway from the first year of destiny
you know vanilla d2 was that the
their players disagreed with them that
their players wanted reasons to log on
they wanted random roles they wanted
that sort of stuff and i think they took
the wrong takeaway because i think what
the community was actually saying is
that
we want to be able to keep playing this
game but we don't want to feel like we
have to
yep and i think that they took we don't
we want reasons to play to like
you need to make us play like it
mandatory in order for us to hit that
bar and i think that
there's a middle ground between those
two things where like i don't feel like
i personally
have to log on and do gambit for 40
hours to be competitive
but i i also have incentives where i
could
i could do that like there's actually a
reason to do it and i think they've
never really
hit that balance and right now they're
on they've kind of swung
back to the d1 days where it's like it's
mandatory if you really like i can't do
grand master dude i play destiny every
day
i saw you with you i saw your tweet i
saw you
15 i'm like way below the it's gonna
take me a really long time to to get up
to uh grand master
it'll probably be right when the season
ends and then the grind begins again
um and i've done the raid every week i
still don't have eyes of tomorrow
uh you know it's just i i
there's there's there's a middle ground
and i
i'm sure i'm making it sound easier than
it is but i just feel like they've never
really gotten to that point spiritually
in destiny where they reward their most
loyal people
without punishing the people who just
want to play casually and and don't feel
like they're being left in the dust
yeah it's this weird artificial thing
they've got right now of the powerful
verse pinnacle where you hit a wall
like a hard hard stop when you're like
level a new person's gonna do the same
thing
soft like powerful cap slows down but
you know you tend to make some progress
even the blues still help
and then you literally hit the wall of
pinnacle and you're like well there's
still just a little bit more
you're limited on how many you can do
like the
summer plus one then you gotta do a raid
for plus two
and there are people i know who will
like put everything together but also on
the other side
as you guys are saying as soon as you
hit the new season it's the same thing
over and over again
and that's i think what hurts the most
like for you teddy if it's like if a
grandmaster
you say it's valuable
to an extent yeah why is what do you get
out of there that has value to someone
like you
i'm honestly curious uh it's usually the
drops i mean the exotics
are really what you're chasing or the
mats right if i want to send in shards
um because i i'm asked to work
everything right
if you look at my inventory it's all
gold i'm going to stay right here
and and every every armor piece in my
inventory has a purpose like i have a
build for
basically every scenario bro yes so this
is scary
whether it's whether it's a weapon or an
armor like i have it in dim where i just
have the
um my loadouts all created for you know
i just did this actually
this week uh because i fixed everything
finally and um
yeah so it's like okay i'm going and uh
i'm gonna casually play strikes all
right i got my i got my
my utility bill we'll call it whatever
it's chaos reach right now
um well i'm gonna play gambit okay i got
i got that built and and
i'll it i just i have something for
everything so gm's facilitate that
um my ability to basically keep that
that
carrot uh or i guess feed the machine is
a better
analogy um now i don't agree with that
especially now the sun setting has gone
like
it makes it makes everything like it it
just felt so much better now because i'm
like okay i don't have to
get a new armor set which was i think
the worst offender of sun setting um
yep but yeah and gyms are fun too like
it
we only we only get one raid a year
typically
um usually and if we get a second one
it's usually not
as big as scope or it's like a reading
like fog this year a rain layer yeah
um and so gm's kind of it i think it's a
more challenging
activity and it's more intimate right
because you're not you're not yelling at
five other people you only get two other
people you're getting
through still yelling yeah so
i i find that fun i i think i think it's
destiny's most
challenging content outside of day one
raid but the thing is you can't go back
and play the raid in its day one form so
you can only experience that why not why
not right yeah
i've also been this is kind of a tangent
but i've also been of the mindset that
like
uh there should be some way to go into
the gm without contest on but you get
less rewards or maybe even no rewards
like
if you just wanted someone to experience
it uh just to basically see what they're
up against kind of
um because not not everyone watches the
youtube video that explains the loadout
or goes on reddit or talks to you know
they're not they're not like us like
even though we're all different types of
players we're all what i would consider
like a top echelon
you know just the fact that we're
sitting on a podcast talking about the
game already makes us
ahead of most people so so
when i have i'm sure they have data to
back this up but i'm on the mindset that
when you allow more people to
participate in your activities you will
ultimately you'll you'll start gaining
um more hardcore people because
you know little jimmy who plays three
hours a week or whatever or or
the dad or whoever um maybe they get to
grandmaster in week 10
of this season it's like okay i want to
try it but they're not they don't have
the loadout right or the gear or maybe
even just the knowledge like the
artifact is not explained
very well or even champion like it's
constantly ready to post about you know
champions aren't explained adequately
and maybe they just want to go in the gm
and try it
and and and do it but it might be too
difficult for them
with the contest mode on so turn that
off and let people participate without
it but give them something less or
maybe nothing at all i mean that's a
little harsh in my opinion but
whatever right just some way to
facilitate that and um i have something
that is
relatable to trials with that but we'll
get into that later because i think we
have a trials topic later but uh
uh just to answer your question like i i
like it for
for the rewards and and how it kind of
continues the loop in in a positive way
but i think the
the letting someone into it is the
problem right um especially when it's
the same
thing every season like it should it
just shouldn't matter
they they could they could make contests
at whatever the pinnacle cap was the
previous season so this is gonna be 310
for the next season
um and just let me start gm's on week
one
and it's the same thing right like i
just make it whatever
325 and and or three at
whatever 340. but yeah
there's there's so many there's so many
solutions to this problem but
like travis said like i'm sure making it
sound like it's easier than it actually
is
yeah create a contest mode version of
these
of the raid that guarantees you and eyes
of tomorrow drop and and all do
flawlessly you know or flawless yeah
like create a way where like your
skill or dedication has gives you stuff
but it's not like the only way to get it
or it's not like it's gating other
people out except for the most elite of
the elite
but it saves you time or gives you
access to it first or something that
the teddies of the world care about
right but i'll get there eventually even
if i don't
uh you know do do every grandmaster
nightfall yeah
yeah when when when the game is
rewarding
that's when destiny is at its best and
it's one that's one of the factors that
make that but like
that's usually when it's at its best and
i i don't know i'm again i'm sure they
have the data to back this up but it is
incredibly frustrating when you get a
scenario like the bottom dollar or the
strike guns currently
where it's just so unrewarding and like
my time
does not feel like i played gambit i
played gambit last week for
last weekend for eight hours with my
friends sorry for your loss yeah i mean
we're having a good time and we're
winning most of the games and i was
going for the dredge and the guild of
dredging titles at the same time sorry i
want to interrupt
can we get a freelance gambit playlist
please oh
please yeah oh that's a good idea that's
a good idea
i just thought gambit was always
freelance
can you imagine can you imagine asking
your friends to group up for gambit
that's an embarrassing conversation to
have anyway
are you asking about a gambit date is
yeah that's date's not going to go very
far yeah so like i
i i played gamer for eight hours and
like for the most part you know it's not
enjoyable but we're not miserable
because we're
we're you know we're kicking the rocks
right like we're we're talking we're
having fun
um i got one one bottom dollar
yeah and it was almost perfectly rolled
but it had hip fire grip on it i thought
you mixed it up which makes it
automatically trash because that
one perk is terrible this led into a
whole different discussion that we had
which was like
do what diablo does where you can let me
reroll one column but that's the only
column i can
roll on that gun going forward forever
and i don't care how many mats it costs
that's a cost right
i will spend it because i put that
ability
getting three out of four perks or two
out of three perks on whatever gun
and that last one just being solarity or
or bottomless grief or something it's
like my time is just so unvalued i get
it not every gun can be
perfect but right but like i would like
to re-offer up my trials idea
yeah yeah
they have this reward problem i don't
know if it's like a fear
or and we've talked about this before
like off air and i think previous
podcast but like
they they just don't want to reward the
player for some reason
like i i don't i don't see the problem
because diablo
i mean borderlands does it to the
extreme right but like diablo does it
pretty well
where you give the player what what they
want or at least at least
kind of what they're chasing and they'll
continue to play diablo has all these
systems that facilitate
um you know you get the one legendary
drop and that might not have the sockets
on it or or the stats you want but at
least there's options to
re-roll it maybe break it down craft a
new one there's all these different
layers that they've implemented and they
didn't think that up overnight right
they took them years to get to that
point but
destiny offers none of that like it's
either because
you don't yeah i think it's because
diablo and borderlands don't have
multiplayer modes i mean that's
i think that's what it boils down to but
but counterpoint
it seems like they don't care about pvp
so then why should the former
matter like you're hurting
i'm saying that you know quotes because
i'm sure they do care right yeah but
they say
they haven't shown it then why does it
matter that
oh i got five third axioms to drop or
five bottom dollars to drop in one hour
of play time like th that shouldn't
matter
at that point but here's i was like i
will say for the pvp side though
you still are gonna have people that
will take
a you know three out of five weapon into
pvp
that's what they got they're happy to
get a bottom dollar even if it doesn't
have hip fire grip they're like i hear
this thing's probably
most people like that most people don't
like that right that's fine and there's
something wrong with that yeah
but then if they think this pvp they
don't want things to get too out of hand
yet some random you know person played
one game a gambit got a five out of five
god roll
the bottom dollar and then now they
theoretically have the better gun that
they were worried about in the first
place but
somebody still does get that every so
often and then somebody could play a
thousand hours and never get that right
gun so why
from what you're saying craft it change
it like i mean i've gotten
i played 60 hours of outright or some
dumbass amount but
like you have you're going to have mud
slots out writers demo yeah the full
game's not even out there that's a
problem but that's me
um but you have mods like hey this
thing's really cool
well let me change one thing out and
guess just as you said it's like
i can make it more powerful i can change
some functionality just the one switch
would do a ton because the four out of
fives
burn a lot of people and but again it's
also they they want the little carrot
hanging out on the stick but again
how is somebody gonna leave your game
are they going to leave it pissed off
that they never got the thing they were
going for
are they going to leave it happy because
dude i finally got this thing
i grinded out these materials i switched
this one thing i love this new gun cool
which one do you want the person to feel
like no that's a good point that's a
good point
actually these guys let me jump i gotta
jump you gotta go go go go go
go great points and i want to get in um
two things one
they attempted to do this in d1 if you
guys remember
um there was a mac
yeah and glass needles remember glass
needles y'all yep that was exotics
yeah that was exotic but that was a star
in the mindset i felt right
and ever since d2 it's been completely
abandoned so
i completely agree with you there should
be something because nothing feels
if you're the hardcore like you know a
teddy and you're doing these hardcore
activities
and you it really feel it sucks to play
trials and you get that celebrity role
you know what i'm saying
and you know it just sucks you your
blood blood sweat and tears you did all
this
and and the investment was not worth it
so there should be it
to teddy's defense he's right like i
don't care how many
mats i spend or you charge on it you
know what i'm saying
but give me give the hardcore the
ability to change the shot to end so
give the hardcore the ability to change
it you know i'm saying because
again it doesn't feel good after all
that investment
to travis's point he's onto something
too as far as when we're talking power
grind like
d2 in my opinion has shout out to the
fire department
because they agree they're upset with d2
[Laughter]
you could say d2 is on fire right now
they're on fire right there clearly
we're hearing the results
anyway the thing that i feel that
they've never
got down is like that again that feeling
of power instead of everything kind of
rising with you
like a boat right like there should be
activities
if you guys remember in d1 one of my
funnest memories
was remember when they brought back our
age of triumph
and they brought the old raids back and
when that you
felt all the cool arm and everything you
felt like a boss going
back into atheon crowd and and just
destroying right there is there is
something about d1 that had that when
the old raid or whatever you came back
in there and you destroyed and they just
they don't have it like they're not
rewarding that person that's going past
that 13
10 that 20 and they're going to that 13
25 they they're just going past this
threshold
that person if he's on my fire team
should be caring and to ease point he
gonna like this
you know that's why a lot of people like
d1 because there were more
hero moments right there were more
moments where that one person who really
committed to the game you were happy to
have him on
your team you would have you know
teddy's in here with that 1325 or
whatever it is
like and he can just solo or take a lot
of the responsibility away
because it's so powerful now everything
is so mechanic-based
everything levels with you so you truly
the
the truly dedicated is not really
getting that advantage they they truly
deserve
and with grand fall night for grant
grandmaster nightfall i get it you know
what i'm saying
you know that that's supposed to be the
pinnacle activity i'm not going to
complain
too much in that regard that it that it
exists and because i honestly i'm like
i really don't care about it only
because i agree with teddy as far as the
activity itself is fun with coordination
planning you know mods builds yes but i
would eat
in that i'm not doing that for shadow
price within the debt
point plus two you know like i'm just
not you know what i'm saying so
again it's this balance like travis said
like they still haven't
found they still haven't rewarded the
hardcore enough
to commit to it or get the
the the guy that's casual to kind of
stay in
to want to do it so i really it's tough
man i the last part i'll say was this
in my clan we got all different levels
of skill
and the top level guy shot the back for
dead is in there sinister's in here
they're in this bungees in this weird
boat because the top level guys of my
clan
do have a sense of pride when they they
pull up into your fire team with their
number over there
like there's a pride about it so and i
think bungie
knows that so they they they definitely
keep in that aspect but i just feel it's
gotta mean more
to easepoint last thing i'm saying is
just that you know
i do feel maybe like i said not every um
season has to be this 50 point thing
maybe 10 point and maybe leave the big
bigger gap for the expansion
but i'm also at a tough spot i just
don't know
how to actually satiate all these
different
players and they're in a tough spot and
i wish i had like this definitive answer
all you got to do is
and it's tough because they've got all
these different they got all this data
all these different type of players
and trying to satisfy all so yeah it's
time there is an easy answer but it's
just not easy to actually do the answer
the answer is just like create a
crapload more content for destiny
that's so much easier said than done
right if they could just like
quadruple their team size and just come
out with content all the time and just
like feed then people wouldn't care
about the power grind because it'd be
having fun doing the events
the problem is the power grind is being
used to supplant
new content and like oh just keep keep
playing gambit and grind for one weapon
because we don't have time to build you
some new strikes or
god forbid a crucible match
you said sun setting is like hey you're
glad your vault is safe with sun setting
now
but also you said you just got done
going through your loadouts you're not
going to have to touch your loadouts for
like
about 10 months you're going to be able
to use those for
lots and lots of time now so now it's
like your incentive to go into grand
master if you're capable of doing them
outside of the number
if you have a loadout for a bunch of
different situations besides hey i need
to play the color match game of shields
here and there
outside of those like now
being as your armor will continue to go
with you you have to infuse it
it's literally all you have to do but it
still should all function the same way
so now where's your incentive if you
have a loadout for every situation
what's your incentive
so the okay so i got there's one thing i
want to come back to but i'll answer
your question first
so there's um the only way that this
works
is they have to make something better
than what was that
what came before which is the reason
that they said sun setting was made
right we didn't want this we had this
power creep problem i agree
and and we're gonna we're gonna make
better you know we're gonna make new
stuff that uh
that will be better than the old stuff
but it's going to go away you know the
the recluse 2.0 that we never got
or the mods that we never got that was
supposed to be better and
um that's you know that's in the past
now but like
for me like i will use that armor until
they make something better or until they
invalidate my progress which will likely
come
first um if you look at destiny sister i
was just talking to my clan mates about
this
uh essentially every major expansion or
new game they've
somehow either invalidated weapons or
armor or both um in some fashion
so if they don't you know next season if
they don't introduce some like crazy
armor that has like a new mod socket on
it and the mods are just absolutely
busted and only that armor takes the
mods then
you know you're right there is no reason
for me to replace it and i'm okay with
that
because i've given sweat blood and tears
to get basically all
64 plus armor pieces in my inventory um
could they be better absolutely the max
is 70 on an armor piece but you know
that that's like
pulling hairs to that point and it
doesn't excuse me it doesn't matter
um you know it that that like
extra discipline i get for the extra
four seconds or whatever
that does not make a difference in my
little that's just you know passively if
i get a better armor piece cool i'm
going to swap it out
so again answer your question like i i
would have to have some new thing that's
just inherently better than the old
thing
which is the power creep problem but i
think as i've talked about on a previous
podcast
because we made they made they use the
analogy of magic the gathering how magic
the gathering has set rotation
they rotate out old cars put new cards
in so they can make more busted cars
that they know eventually will go away
i think that model works for a card game
i don't think that model works for
destiny and i think destiny's model is
more akin to yu-gi-oh if you're familiar
with that game which they have a
forbidden
ban a forbidden and limited list where
cards basically get forbidden
or limited to one um throughout time and
as new cards come out they make better
and better cards that are more balanced
usually occasionally get an outlier
excuse me
and um over time older cards will come
off that list and and and uh be allowed
and they're not broken at that point
because there's just better stuff and
destiny
sort of functions like or has function
like that where they'll take away a
weapon from you and then they bring it
back but then that weapon's not really
as good anymore because there's just
better stuff
um and it's a fine balancing act right
like they've never they've never gotten
it
perfectly at any point but i think sun
setting was
not the solution especially when at
least i think sun setting was made
because of the five pinnacle weapons
that were
through um
so i i will keep playing because
i like getting that point five percent
better but it's not a requirement like i
don't
i don't need to do that that just
happens because i'm playing
um you know if the gm drops me a phoenix
protocol
please r g guys give me a phoenix
protocol that's not 20 mobility
i need a phoenix with like 20 mobility
for me
that would be great if i got that but i
don't need that um
so it's just at that point it's either
like a triumph or a fun factor
or um you know a friend needs or a clan
mate needs it or something
we can go through it um the thing i
wanted to bring up because we're talking
about the rng
feeling sorry before i lose my train of
thought no no please please because
we're talking about this off the air too
so you're talking about how it feels to
not get the thing
and i did uh deep stone crypt for 33
runs over the course of whatever amount
of weeks that was
and i did not get it tomorrow until the
34th run
i did not feel joy or happiness when it
jumped i just felt
i just felt relief it was like i'm done
like it's it's over i don't have to
stress about this stupid gun and then of
course the gun got
broken it wasn't even good
um and the same thing happened with uh
with the messenger when it popped up for
the three wins
i did it on all three characters did all
the bounties and every single one had
celerity on it
oh that doesn't feel good
at all like that feels awful and it just
me it was like i don't want to play like
i just i
didn't play that weekend i think after
that i was like i'm done like i'm not
touching this game this game can go in
the trash like
it's over and then of course i come back
the next week
we're an abusive relationship but yeah
that was the only point i want to bring
up um
so we're talking about that i want to
lose my train of thought on that because
we talked about it off the air a little
bit but uh
i got to actually i noticed this we go
along but i got to ask you both this
question i didn't get a chance to
discuss and e we briefly discussed
when we were talking about the proud
creep so now that sun setting is
gone right you know we were told prior
that the reason it exists is for power
creep and and i agree with you teddy
that
you know things like recluse mountaintop
you know with just
these things that break yeah you know
these things were just broken they were
just
getting too hard for them to control and
to balance right
so now that sun sitting is gone as
travis like we'll say like
does that really solve the problem like
how do you think
they solve the problem of things are
going to just now stay
stay with us i guess effectively all the
way you know to which queen or whatever
that that new limited
like how do you think they solve that
because theoretically
power creeps still he's still going to
be here so that that's what i want to
know like do you think this is just them
again for now or
you know how do you think they you know
even addressed this that i'm very
curious i've never got a chance to ask
both of you guys
so anyway go ahead travis yeah i don't
even think that they know
how they're going to address it and i
think they kind of admitted as much in
the
the 12 where they said like hey here's
the problem we're trying to solve the
sandbox needs to be refreshed every once
in a while where people aren't just
using the same
weapon same three or four weapons over
and over again um
and i think everyone in the destiny
community recognizes that that's a
problem i don't think that
anybody is like hoping that we're just
going to use reclusive mountaintop for
like
forever you know and that's just going
to be destiny okay all right so teddy
hopes that
daddy holds the monster i was like i'm
gonna come back to that
he's a monster yeah he would you would
go crazy
i i think that the solution
isn't to necessarily i mean if obviously
power creep
can't be a thing but there's nothing
there's nothing that hurts
somebody else's existing build to
introduce new things to the game and i
think that that's what needs to happen
they need to come up with new perks and
great guns that only have
that perk because it existed after that
time and that doesn't hurt an old weapon
it just gives a new way of playing they
can create guns that operate in new ways
and armors with a new mods that can be
applied to
various armors there's like lots of ways
to do it it's just that those ways are
really hard because you have to spend a
ton of development time coming up with
new perks and
balancing them and i can't even imagine
how hard that becomes to then balance
your sandbox when there's like
50 perks instead of 20 right so that's
difficult
um and and that sort of thing but i
think that
i think the solution to just like
takeaway weapons
is way easier right because all you have
to do is just say
all right those weapons are gone and
then just with a magic wand you've
solved your problem and now you've given
them a lot of different reasons to grind
um yeah i mean there
i think either there's two ways out of
this one is
don't make it so much about the loot
make it the ways that you use the loot
make more activities make more content
and destiny that people love to play
and play that just for that but that's a
resources problem
and then the other solution is to
continue the way they're going
you know not not create as much content
because maybe it's just not feasible in
a game of the size
uh and then create different types of
weapons and armor that just
are not more powerful just different
right that have different mods and that
sort of thing only attainable on that
stuff yeah yeah i i think and i think
both of those pads out are extremely
resource intensive and i don't know that
they
have a solution that isn't and the one
that they had they tried
and then gave up on it almost
immediately which he still boggles my
mind
that's the same thing
like to me it's like if you can convince
a team of like 600 people
or at least the leaders of that team
that like you're gonna make this huge
change to destiny that would strike to
me
as like something that they like bought
over
and were tormented by and like should we
do it and then when they made that
decision that they were gonna like stick
to their guns forever and the fact that
like
they gave it kind of a try for like two
seasons and then immediately back down
on it that blows my mind
it was that bro i should just they just
didn't stand up for what they
they they thought they believed in and
maybe maybe that's good maybe that's
like humility and them realizing hey we
are wrong
and they're listening to the community
but maybe it's just like
maybe they just didn't give it a chance
and that was the path forward because
i was a guy who was defending
sunsetting with the caveat that they
were going to try new stuff and make
things that were broken and not care
and then right that was fine because if
things went away a season later
you know you could you could have fun
that way and i still think they can do
that i think that they can
create pinnacle weapons where when you
earn them the understanding is that
they're only going to be around for that
season
right there's nothing wrong with that
and then you can still grind your bottom
dollars and your stuff like that but
then for the really crazy weapons
the pinnacles their own they those are
the only weapons that do sunset and i
think that there's middle grounds that
allow people to change the sandbox and
and pull in new stuff
uh without breaking everything but yeah
i just
i i'm i'm i'm with you like i'm just
appalled like how how the heck did they
make such a huge decision and then just
immediately just all right yeah four
months later all right
see ya blows my mind yeah i'm with you
i'm with you on that the surprise
and the in the resource thing but i know
we're going along i just i just had
because i
have talked about you so i wanted to get
that off no that's
literally why i wanted everybody in here
today is because
we're at kind of a not a breaking point
for the game we never really are we know
what the game's always going to survive
but there is a point where all these
things
feel like they're up in the air i've
said my eyes are literally looking out
to which queen
why because that's when like an armor
3.0 is going to even matter and as you
one of i think teddy you said
there's a point they make some of your
stuff irrelevant with an expansion
hence why for me especially why the hell
am i gonna grind out any armor this
season if i've got a masterwork set
that's gonna get me through the year
when witch queen is likely and even
there was a point that i think it was
joe blackburn said
they want to make sure armor's not this
thing hey i want to replace the stats
every year
so they're they have some plan of a new
armor system in the works whether it's
new mods that's the matter
i don't know how they're going to do it
but it's going to be something different
that's what you said is their way
to make stuff new and make stuff
reasonably attainable
and maybe with their huge yeah there's
like
uh cool j has done some cool like trials
and weapons and armor and stuff 2.0 to
take things to
another level and all these little
pieces that they need to implement of
why do i want to go after this weapon
okay it's got some cool perks on it
well these are new perks that we
implemented are they any better or are
they different
and then that's always one of those
things at some point they're going to
run out of how different can we continue
to make this stuff
is it going to be about yeah it's like
how long for another three and a half
years
because we know there's three plus now
which queen
lightfall plus 10 or plus you know year
10
how many more perk varieties are they
going to come up with
i mean just look at exotics yeah i mean
that's the thing it actually kind of
blows my mind that exotics are the one
weapons that didn't get sunset and armor
that didn't get sunset because they're
the most broken and then legendaries
which are just some of them were kind of
powerful
got annihilated right that's crazy to me
because it seems like you would think
the opposite like the outliers that are
exotic that can do all these crazy
things we get sunset but they were like
no no those are safe we like it but yeah
i get it you can only
you want to do it once that's why yeah
it's
that just blows my mind that'll go to
you um
but yeah it's like that's kind of the
idea is like my wonders how different
are things ever get like you see frenzy
i'm like okay cool
it's another way to get damage you've
had your rampage you had your kill clip
you had your multi-kill clip you've had
multiple different ways you even have
lasting impression what does it do a
delayed timer
for more damage like we all tend to lean
that direction whenever one comes out
because why you still want higher dps
that's what most
people are generally going to lean for
if they start looking into min maxing at
all
you've got your armor which is upping
your stats why because you're likely to
get your super faster
it's either survivability or more damage
usually most of the things so i'm
curious to see what they do with like an
armor 3.0
that's probably what has me most
intrigued that far out
but the other thing that has me
intrigued lately has been the story
and i do want to like see what you guys
how you guys have been taking into the
story at this point to say
honestly like that's why i log in every
week
like the the seasonal challenges are
fine the other pieces are okay
i literally want to know what the
interaction is for the week
now it kind of bugs me that it's once a
week and i get like 30 minutes this
little baby quest and get my little drip
feed here and there
we'll get to that in a second but like
the story that like
beyond light was cool we had elsie and
clovis sadly i think
we'll come back to that in about eight
months but like this season's story the
way they've delivered it
has actually been really really cool and
i've enjoyed like seeing the progression
of the characters the voice over during
the battlegrounds
more voiceover than i think we probably
ever have had in a season
ever um and then obviously this one
was we saw kyle take over the twitter
account which is hilarious because that
might be in canon now
and we also have her denying the attack
on zavala we have the in-game cinematic
we talked about last week
done with like the storyboards which is
you know fantastic to see that little
type of way to see
in your face storytelling this time i
log in this week and zaval is basically
all right kyle that's 1v1 like that's
kind of how it sounds but it's going to
be by champion
and it honestly won bro yeah it's like
so i was kind of curious how you guys
think the story has gone so far and
where you think this season
story is going to end up we get a season
pass
strike next week which is a little weird
because it's like a week delayed for
everybody else
um so that's going to be tied into the
story so it's kind of curious you guys
thoughts i'm going to check on my dog
again
uh story discussion i'm going to say
teddy tag you're head
um i like it so far i
basically have always i mean i i start
in destiny in general which is
part of the reason i play but um the
main expansions are usually what
matters and those are generally also
what propel the story forward
yeah yeah like the seasonal expansions
generally
are giving you sort of a side story oops
a side story that
kind of at the end of it relates to
something that's happening in in the
main story and i think that's by design
i think they do that
potentially um because i i think since
taking king they've had this maybe it's
evolved but they've had this vision of
where they want that scene to go from
that point forward second king was
basically the
you know the starting point for
everything that's happened up until now
that was the catalyst
um i think the seasonal stuff is just
like it's cool
and the catalyst is interesting i like
it um i'm pissed for fighting cabal
again for like the fourth or fifth year
in a row but
uh yeah i mean it's yeah it's it's not
like
a 10 out of 10 but it's yeah i'm glad we
have it and the crow's stuff is
obviously the most interesting
i think aspect of because this character
is so unique and
i'm happy they're kind of exploring that
dynamic um
for him so yeah
let me ask i'm sorry go ahead no that's
it
no i'm just saying like um no i
completely hear you on that these those
interesting story beats and stuff like
that
so gonna ask travis like what about you
in reference to the narrative the story
this season
you know how are you feeling is that
giving you incentive to keep coming in
or is it something like meh
not as much no totally um i mean
obviously i talk about a lot about how
like the main reason i log in is to make
blueberries cry in crucible but
um actually i i am a huge lore guy
i mean you we've talked about on the
show that like i
tend to catch on to certain stuff
and just like dive into it uh times a
thousand and destiny is one of those
things where
um you know i think i'm a few months
behind on like some of the lore
stuff right now just because as you know
i don't like to do do stuff i don't want
to do in destiny so like
getting pressured nine times to get all
of the uh lore entries like nah it's
cool man i'll just read it online
bro it's just stuff like that but it's
just a trap
it's just a top
i actually do really like uh the story
and the lore in destiny
actually on fire team chat today they
everybody laughed at me for bringing up
uh am tech
the scion just because
paul and destin didn't know who he was
and they were just like nerd
[Laughter]
paul has no room to talk about the lore
because honestly we all know that he's
like
okay done videos about it paul wrote
fanfic
yeah about uh the cancellation of trials
last week
so like he he truly has no room to talk
that loser
uh but yeah they were making fun of me
for that but
um i actually think this is the best
season of uh destiny
uh and i mean i mean like season not
like main expansion and that's just
because
the main activity is actually fun it's i
mean i don't like doing it
every week you know three or four
battlegrounds a week i i
i but it is at least a brief and it's
more entertaining than
you know 90 percent of the other
seasonal activities we've had to do
um i think the story is really good i
love that they've actually
got people in spaces doing stuff or
seeing characters interact and that sort
of thing i think that's really great
i have two criticisms when it comes to
storytelling one
i really wish that they would do some of
the storytelling
in the world like you know how destiny 2
vanilla we got to see like
zavala uh he actually put down his titan
bubble and we got to hang out with st
14 and season of the dawn you know i i
want to hang out with guardians like on
the battlefield rather than going to
like a social zone
he like preaches that which you said
yeah he's like
yeah why can't zavala drop in at the end
of the battleground and have the
conversation or
you know in the middle of it even to
kind of like break up some of the stuff
i just think that
they're trying to make it so that the
story of destiny is optional and that's
sort of at odds with i think
most of the people who are playing
destiny at this point um
you know luke smith said a while back
that
destiny he wanted destiny to be the game
that you could like play with your
friends while you're watching the oscars
you know like it's like something you
can do as like a side activity
and i think that that's like
shitty i don't want that
at all i i like i i okay so
a caveat i actually do like that because
sometimes when i have to grind i'd i'll
like put on a tv show and just watch it
while i mindlessly grind but i don't
think
yeah i i don't think that that's like
their idea i don't think that's ideal
state of playing i think ideally
especially when you're doing like pve
content you want a you want something
that's closer to
uh the the uh deep stone crypt raid
right where like
you're playing it but stuff's happening
like their story's unfolding and you're
kind of being taken on this cool
adventure while you
while you play i think that we need to
get get closer to that
um so yeah that's my first criticism is
more stuff needs to happen
during and my second criticism is i hate
that all of the major plot points happen
off screen
and i mean i mean off screen like
completely off screen like
the fact that osiris lost his ghost oh
in like lord
and it's just completely gone uh you
know
like all that stuff about all the cool
stuff that's happened with the crow we
have like this crow character who's
awesome
i will say i loved it in season the hunt
we actually saw
the interaction with the spider and we
got to get him off though that is what
i'm talking about like that was really
going to probably go back to the
game but there's there's so much cool
stuff
in the destiny world that they keep at
the periphery and i think it's because
they're afraid of scaring away the
casual audience that wants to skip every
cut scene
but you know newsflash bungie like you
can put a skip cutscene button for those
people
and still leave room for people like us
who actually want to see it so
i i i'm loving it so far i'm really
excited to see where it goes and then if
i can just jump to your second question
which was how do i think it's gonna end
um i think i think something's going up
with
i i don't know if kaidel's tweets are
canon
that she said if i killed zavala i'd do
it uh
looking in the eyes but that sort of
implies that she didn't send the scion
to assassinate zavala and if that's the
case the question is who did it
um i was making an argument on fire team
chat today that it could be am tech
which they laughed at because they
nobody knows who tech is fair point
nobody knows who am tech is for those of
you who don't know
and are watching the show uh she's the
fourth scion sister
uh from season of the dawn where we were
fighting those three magical scions and
she
is sort of like a renegade force right
now within the cabal and
and possibly might have incentive to
undermine uh kaidal so that that would
be a good way to
eliminate her own enemy by pissing off
the guardians and sending them after her
um but i think
probably a more likely story because
there's been set up for it is that
sabathune has something to do with it
um and and and possibly is like playing
these dominoes because
it's in savathun's interest if she's
gonna attack us
to divide us right and to not let us
ally with the cabal and i think that
would be
an interesting plot point i don't think
they'll do it i i think we'll just
kill you know kyle's big uh colossus
monster
next week and then kyle will bend the
knee and that'll be
the end of it but uh i hope i'm wrong i
hope they surprise us and i hope they
start doing more stuff
uh in the actual game i would just love
that so no you're on fire man i mean i
i'm with you i think
you know he said it best it's literally
a routine of me logging in on tuesday
what's gonna happen and it's different
for me from destiny because usually
tuesday to reset day
i have my own specific agendas for stuff
but i i gonna run i race over to the
helm
i want to see what's going on you know
um i i
completely agree with traffic they can
do more but
you know i'm a huge voice actor guy i
love
the the fact that we're getting multiple
people involved
in a season because to me the prior
cadence was always
focused on one or two this is the error
season
this is the season of the drifter where
it's just this one
and then i in my mind i'm always like
well what the hell is saladin doing
i'm learning now you know he chose not
to help in the red war he has
regrets you know you're learning about
the relationship with um
amanda i don't know if you caught it but
you know there was a crazy voice joint
this week where it was like um
crow and a man and the man is like you
know talking about the
the the loss of kade and how that
affected her and he's like yeah i wish i
would have met him
and i'm like oh boy let's go on your
interest and she she's like yeah
you know you need to come into the tower
we need to have a drink and i'm like oh
this is gonna get interesting
do tell right so it's stuff like that
and
i'm loving again multiple things you got
the osiris
kind of mentoring crow in a way you know
i'm saying you shouldn't have did this
you shouldn't do that i'm trying to be a
better guardian and the thing i like and
i've been you know
really hard on them about being about
saladin
only being the weekly iron band event
render
and acting like he has no major role in
the overarching story
you know this season yeah finally like
i'm learning about
saline what was he doing why does he
feel this way you know and he's just
going wrong
he wants to kill every who ever lived
it's hilarious
bro he is like forget this diplomacy
gets they tried to assassinate then he's
like zavala
soft like he he's just in his bag i i
love where salad is going this whole
thing my only little nitpick because i'm
being greedy
i would like to know where saint is and
i agree with what he's doing what he's
thinking
you know and i agree with travis like
too many of the stuff
is off screen right i shouldn't have to
always read a lore piece
to know like he said osiris goes die
like what's going on with saying and i
think
someone i think i don't know if it's
bearded luke or someone we had on e
who said it best and help me actually
understand
you know why they're doing that and i
think what was said was
that um a lot of the stuff you notice
that happens off
tends to be darker stuff people dying
you know like just very more dark and i
forgot i think it was beating luke and
he was just like a lot of it comes
down to i forget destiny is a
teen rated game so i think a lot of it
comes down to
what they feel they can get away with
for this this age group audience
and then anything they may want to go
deeper you know they do off-screen now i
don't like it
i'm not i'm not trying to make excuses i
still feel there's a better happy medium
i still feel like
driver said i would love for for
guardians to drop
in strike you know what i mean while we
in the closest i think i've ever felt
was cursed osiris with osiris when
you're fighting benaptis and he's in
the mix with you like we want to see
more like saint 14 he's got the bubble
out
and you want to see it they're so close
but in their defense
this has been exciting to me i really
like
the the tulip there's a tune in next
week you know
cartoon kind of vibe you know what i'm
saying but yeah
they're utilizing a lot a little bit
more improvement with certain things
but if they keep this i'm a guy that
really values narrative
i love i care about these characters
we've been in with them so
long you know what i'm saying and to no
motivations to know everything's not
this big happy family
to know people are arguing and then we
know the eventual reveal
with crow that mask came off a couple
times like it's getting there
and i want to know how they handle it
and shout out to the narrative team
like i said as much as i give them crap
and stuff like that with cohesion and
going into a raid and stuff like
that they've really they're getting into
a nice
pocket and i just hope it continues and
that's probably the strength
of where i agree with travis that why i
love this season too much
besides the fact that evil though i
think battlegrounds was way too many too
many i love battlegrounds but way too
many battlegrounds i got to do
no i was like i actually wanted to take
what you said as well is
when you're in battlegrounds when you
finish them up you have like i have 60
seconds why because there's usually
voice dialogue at the end there's a
little bit as you go through
and you learn a little bit about these
characters yes and it is a very delicate
line for them to walk to say
here's the voice acting lines in this
battleground cool i learned a little bit
more more about these characters
when i run my 12 000th battleground do i
give a
[ __ ] about the lie the characters
anymore
do i like like that's kind of the deal
as you said do they if they continue to
build those lines in there
some of that's going to get missed there
are people who just check out of
battlegrounds and be like i am
done so the fact that you have to go so
they're trying to use the activity to
tell the story which is not a bad thing
like if they did that in a a bit more of
an organic way again
i don't know how they delicately walk
that because it's like if i need to play
five every week just to hear everything
yeah it's the same thing like yeah and
it's perfect you gotta go and do five
battlegrounds i'm like that's too damn
many after a while it's like 60
battlegrounds later
i get it okay i've heard some stuff most
people are probably tuning out
halfway through that run right yeah but
it is just never gotten it right
yeah it's like and i don't know how they
they're getting closer with like i loved
seeing zavala
saladin osiris talking going back and
forth over the table i was like i love
it
that's sitting in front of me on screen
now granted please please please
sorry this is my bungee please for the
week let's go can you fix like the
proximity volume if i look at him
yeah if i turn away it lowers his volume
stop that
please just like make it in the room
however you do audio design just
fill the room however you got to do it i
don't know um that's my one just make
sure it's not directional audio
where i yeah i think uh they've come a
long ways
from giving you the story while you're
loading into the strike
you know that was like their original
solution and i think everybody was like
this is bad but also loading times on
the 360.
i mean xbox one like they're kind of
making the best of a bad situation but
i think they've massively they've gotten
into a point everywhere
yeah i think i think they're starting to
realize that like people love
like the story or at least care about it
or at least their fan base that remains
still does
yeah there's still ways to to get it to
stop but i i
there's still ways for people to skip if
if they want but i've always wondered
like
why isn't there like a raid mechanic
where it relies on
you know eris moore and like throwing
down like a a pool
for you guys to like all step in or you
know something like that where like the
characters are helping you in the world
because they already have so many
mechanics in the raid that seem like
they're out of nowhere it's like
oh hey this thing happened and now
there's bombs spawning and you need to
go and put the bombs in the box you know
and i'm like why why isn't there just
like you know some character pulling a
lever
who's like messing with you guys that
you can see and like why don't they use
that to like build up
you know and they could do that for like
mechanics that help you too like have
like a korra show up and
help you with a certain mechanic in a
raid and she's kind of like playing with
you and
she does something that like triggers
part of the the puzzle that gets you to
damage phase or whatever like
it seems so obvious but again you know
like i'm not a developer i'm sure it's
way harder
than it actually is and i'm sure there's
risks but i think
i think you're right thing i write cog i
think the the main thing that's holding
them back
is that they're afraid of scaring people
away like i think that's what it comes
down to
and i don't buy the at all the whole
teen rating yeah
by the way dude we saw k-6 just get like
massacred on his back like point-blank
was actually
off-screen it's like a disney like they
they looked at the guns
his jaw's like hanging off he you know
it's but they don't say he's also not
human
yeah yeah i mean technically
everything that's died what okay yeah we
saw the speaker die off screen that was
terrible off screen
no one died on screen really
i mean even pictures into like wispy
vapers
like bro it's the team you can't do that
in a cutscene
they have yet to do it i until someone i
don't know i wouldn't think it was big
i i made me think about i said yo he's
right
who do we really see on screen get
mangled or anything vicious that we're
like i get that it's dark
they've done dark stuff they you know
the speaker got tortured he's a human
he got killed off screen but he still
was a cut scene i think
their fear isn't really content i think
their fear is that the lore and destiny
is super dense
most people have no idea what's going on
in destiny right every time they've
tried to do something deep like
the audience has just been lost like i
played uh the destiny 2 vanilla campaign
with somebody who's never played it
before
right before it got taken out and put
into the vault and she was just like
i have no clue what's happening and i
was just like yep i'm sorry
i could explain it to you and she was
like i'm good uh
on that one so you know it's it's uh i
think i think the main thing is that
like it it's just intimidating it's
dense
there's just so much to explain it's
extremely specific and like nerdy and i
think
it it's easy to get scared or to just
make it optional
and that's what they've been doing is
they've just been making it optional
chat made a good point they did say
didn't that one cabal
oh yeah the console dominance goals
console i think he did choke he gets
choked
he got it but again
i really thought that guy was going to
be the main villain and like
you're projecting emperor palpatine is
what you were doing
i thought
this creepy wizard was gonna like use
his medallion or something and
it wasn't that at all perfect for the go
for the jugular
yeah so so i kind of actually have star
wars knowledge for this
okay so podcast about the shift
so when you're ready uh you guys can
take like a waterproof
so when you watch when you watch star
wars and i'm just gonna use the first
six movies because
the sequel trilogy kind of exists on its
own like you don't have to watch that to
understand
the skywalker saga um
when you watch the six movies the movies
give you enough knowledge
to be to ascertain like what's happening
and and the story
are are they amazing or perfect no but
like
the at least they give you the
foundational understanding of this is
the universe these are the rules of the
universe and this is what happens and if
you want to
go into the expanded stuff the comics or
the books or the tv shows
that's where kind of you can get that
supplementary knowledge that either
enhances what you've already seen on
this on screen on the movies or
um gives you a new perspective
especially in the case of like the clone
wars the clone wars is all about
different perspective destiny is kind of
the opposite where destiny
here's the game we're not going to give
you the base knowledge and understanding
you need of the game but it's all
fair it's just in originally it was
grimoire cards and now it's lore
and that's fine like i i think if you're
someone that enjoys that
is it the best solution no i don't think
so but i
i'm curious to hear your thoughts on
whether this
their multimedia strategy now that they
just announced i think last month or
or the month before i can't remember
where they basically said we're getting
a new studio we're gonna have different
avenues of stuff whatever
i wonder if they're if their strategy in
the future maybe two three four years
down the road is here's this tv show
kind of like what the clone wars did
yeah
that supplements and here's where sakira
died here's this here's this whole work
on osiris four episodes of osiris going
and trying to figure out what cyber
thing is doing oh segura just died and
that's the end of the arc right and and
that
kind of gives you that background
context because the clone wars did that
for star wars it gave you
such a better understanding of what was
actually happening and when you think
about it
the prequels are actually an amazing
vision that george lucas had it was just
executed super poorly
on screen but the cloner has like
justified all of it it made almost all
of it relevant and important aside from
jar jar binks i don't think he can fix
that yeah but like
yeah it redeems darth maul which i think
is there yeah
and they made a whole new character like
ahsoka is an incredible character
despite people not liking her in the
beginning
i think her arc is just so important and
obvious it's connected with anakin as
well but like
it's such an important thing and i think
destiny is kind of missing that
it doesn't necessarily have to be a tv
show like if they released a halo style
book
about destiny that was like the the
story of the iron lords right and this
is this is this amazing narrative i'd go
read that right like
and it's nothing it doesn't necessarily
give you new knowledge
because all that story has already been
documented in the grimar somewhere in
the lore but it gives you
a different perspective or more context
to the events that have already happened
and
that just makes you appreciate when
saladin gets pissed at zavala a little
bit more right it gives that moment more
gravitas
um so i'm curious to see if what you
guys think if that
maybe that's our solution going forward
we have this kind of base seasonal model
that's gotten better since
it's like season the rivals basically
has the same model we had now where you
have the same activity you're kind of
doing
and it's delivering the narrative
through the activity and there's a lot
there's a lot of stuff
packed in there um but it's not enough
and a lot of it happens off screen or
it's just dialogue so
i'm curious to see what you guys think
if maybe that's the solution or maybe
there's another solution
what do you think i was just gonna say
for me it's stuff like when you take the
books of sorrow to figure out about oryx
the depth that you can go to understand
incredible story yeah
the the depth you get of his background
that is like really really really cool
and that's like one of my
videos was like the lore of oryx
is better but the story of kyle is
better because it's in game in front of
you
and i think that's the balance of what
they're doing now
with the in-game voice dialogue seeing
the three of them talking
more of that is what i really want to
see in the game and then if you want a
supplemental piece to say
hey this is what you know these are the
tales of lord saladin and the iron lords
these
this is you know the adventures of
osiris through the
corridors of time what those would be
like amazing offshoots tv shows to give
depth to the characters and you go back
and you're like
that you know that makes sense but also
when you go back to the game if this is
going to be the foundation of it
that stuff can't be completely out of
context we still need a little bit of
like
the little storyboard cinematic of hey
osiris has been going through time he
went over here he's been looking for
this
like a little bit of what's
understanding he got into this crazy
blue olive super segura killed him like
that stuff does still need to be shown
for major plot points like that but i
think the depth of like
a book of sorrows or like a history of
the iron lords that stuff
i would love to see that in the other
venues like a comic as you said the
books
tv shows like destiny is ripe for just
an infinite number of tv shows about all
the characters
the history like you could do the you
know the the characters saint 14 like
what he went through like his timelines
and then like go back they could screw a
one division with him or something
there's a lot you could do now granted
is everybody gonna love it i don't know
but
it's like there's a lot that i would be
entertained by but i think as long as
the game is the foundation of where all
this is coming from
the main story beats still need to be
presented visually in front of us
in some way not buried in an article on
the bungie blog
so i i agree i agree i think the last
point i i think i'm leaning
to what um what you call it saying it in
a sense teddy's saying in reference to
i think that's their overall arcing plan
i think the elevation of luke and mark
noseworthy to this like i call it the
kevin feige status of the of the
universe you know
because they are looking to expand this
thing into different media whether it's
movies
you know what you call it a series
animated series or whatever
and i think that is the the long play
you know i'm saying obviously we know
that they've done
extremely well you know recently you
know i'm saying when we find out about
this expansion and then
you know the publishing studio and stuff
like that you know we've been following
the twitter accounts you see them
yelling out for the top of their lungs
bungee like there's this unified
you know decree internally like they the
vibe i get is they are feeling
good about what the future holds
so when i see that and then i see this
elevation and now blackburn now is our
day-to-day in a sense
luke smith you know and luke smith knows
where to go up there
you know i think that's the vision but
it's it's going to be this balance right
where they're going to have to tell
these stories and we have this this
great law
but i do agree with e not everything
should be just reserved they'll be
holding to that
they have to still find that balance in
game
where we are just not completely missed
out and it's like
you know oh you didn't read the
anthology or you didn't you didn't watch
the cop
like it can't be everything in in these
different mediums you know what i'm
saying so it and that's the fine line
that they're gonna have to navigate you
know what i'm saying so
i think that's the eventual plan i think
this game is super rich with law
i don't know if you guys seen shout out
to uh paul tassie um
like there's just big crazy in the
community i just got wise to about
yeah i didn't even know about this whole
plague thing and everybody wants siva to
come back and
you know all this stuff and it's pretty
cool so it goes to show you
the law is there the law is rich there's
a lot of things that you can do a lot of
possibilities
and it's just a matter of how they
handle it and the mediums they choose
but
again that healthy balance cool side
project cool stuff
but also you know major plot points
stuff like that it can't
all be buried in the external stuff
that's what we'll do
okay yeah i'm gonna take you guys to
sci-fi church now
okay so uh i'm gonna i
i've so i think about this a lot like my
brain when it comes to destiny is like
30
pvp and then the other 70 is like me
thinking about
where destiny fits in the sci-fi
storytelling lexicon
and i i have i have really like
pessimistic views about destiny's future
when it comes to this
because unfortunately like obviously i
want them to succeed i'm going to watch
whatever
like content they come out with but i i
just am worried about it and the reason
is because
shows like the clone wars and comic
books and that sort of stuff it only
works if like the core
content is something that people care
about and i think people care about
destiny as a game but i don't think that
there's a lot of people who care about
destiny
on like a character storytelling level
unfortunately like i'm in the minority
i'm i'm on fire team chad and i'm the
only guy who reads the lore right like
that's
that's like just the the the reality of
the situation there's not a ton of us
there's not a ton of bifes in the world
and i think in in science fiction i'm a
huge like student of science fiction
there's
sort of two schools of thought there's
the hard sci-fi
like star trek and those shows are
designed to
answer the questions of how
when it comes to science fiction we want
to know like how the world works
what what what are we gonna what is the
world going to look like in the future
how are we going to
exist what will society look like right
like it's those questions of like how
will things work
right and then there's stuff like star
wars
and destiny that are in the space opera
category and they answer questions of
why
like you don't care about like how luke
skywalker flew across the galaxy
in half a second you care about like why
he's doing it you care about like why
this war is happening it's like an
emotional uh
very human sort of reason you're doing
it and i'm a
despite being a huge science fiction
junkie i really
like um space opera because of it the
way that it humanizes those questions
and it makes you ask
why and i think that destiny is really
bad at
answering those questions of why most
people don't know why we're doing things
we don't know why that you know the
taken king wants to
uh conquer humanity right like you can
if you if you look into the lore but i
think
unless you're answering those questions
in like daylight where a lot of
community sees it it's really hard for
people to attach and care about those
things and
they're they're just not good at
answering questions of why and
this is another thing like teddy and i
talk about this a lot because we're big
fans of uh of star wars
including some of the prequels uh namely
the last jedi
or sorry the sequels namely the last
jedi where where there's like this
attitude in the star wars community
where people go like oh like how could
princess leia survive in space and and
all that [ __ ] like this is you know
ridiculous
and to me i'm like you're watching the
wrong thing dude it's a it's space
with aliens using lightsabers to like
dance around each other like what the
hell
are you yeah like really you wanna
that's your question
like man shoots lightning out of his
hands
space it's it's those questions that
really take away from
what star wars is there for and i think
what destiny should be there for which
is answering those questions of like
why like why do humans want to continue
living in the world
of destiny why is it important to keep
humanity alive
why is the light important why is the
dark bad and i think those questions of
why in destiny are really put off to the
side
and i think what's even worse is that in
destiny we also don't get the star trek
what right like the hard sci-fi we don't
get like
that that take on it either so there's
sort of like this very surface level
because it's space opera we don't have
to explain anything to a certain extent
that is true you don't have to explain
how or what but you do have to explain
why like that's
crucial in space opera you have to make
people care on an emotional level
or it's just avatar it's just
like something that nobody cares about
right it's just the silly like
edward scissorhands like who cares it's
funny like i you know i don't
and that's not what that's not what
attracts fan bases
people love star wars because it makes
them feel and it makes them
ask the questions of why and they relate
to those characters and you know star
wars is decorated with the science
fiction stuff but that's not really what
it's about
destiny isn't it shouldn't be about you
know
the taken or it shouldn't be about space
wizards it should be
about characters that make you feel
something and i
i think destiny has a lot of development
to do before we care about like
comic books or tv shows and i i just
don't think we're there yet so
that's me obviously i think it's like a
super uphill battle it's really hard to
become a star wars they earned that
reputation over 40 years but like
absolutely
you know uh sorry 30 years but getting
on coming on 40.
uh and and uh i i think that that they
they have to fight that one day at a
time
and and you know i'm sure tv shows will
help but i i honestly don't think that a
tv show would do great
uh given where destiny's story is and
how much it's player base really cares
about it right now
i wanted to ask um so do you think
more people for those who played destiny
1 versus destiny 2
do you think more people had a better
understanding of the vagueness of
destiny 1 story
or do you think people got more of
destiny 2's drip story
which one do you think is a better way
to deliver a story for what you're
saying like a general audience to
come into being a fan base like i want
to see you know something about saladin
because we got to see him and
you know fill in the blank how do you
think it's better to build that fan base
do you think it is the old or do you
think it is the new
i think the new way of doing it is
probably the future i just think it
needs to be way more digestible because
destiny 1 got something right in that it
was
it was short enough to be digestible
like everyone understood what was
happening in the taking king i feel like
there were some like after you kill the
taken king and then he takes himself and
you're like what the heck
what did you just do and then i remember
after the credits you get that eris
morgan cut scene and everyone in the
community was like oh my god air sworn's
betraying us and that's just not at all
what was happening remember
so there were like parts of it where
people were like i don't really
understand what's going on but i think
on the whole like the the storytelling
was simple enough to where
people were like all right i get it
destiny 2 has a problem where it's doing
a better job at telling the story but
it's just suffering from bloat there's
so many characters
there's so many different factions and
kaido versus callus versus gaul versus
you know you have to break it down in
like 50 different ways and you really
you know you need bife to be there to
even understand what the hell is going
on right like
and i think that's a new problem for
destiny in in a certain
a certain way um so i think i think what
they have to do is just like
pull back and tell like a smaller story
and just build on that i think they did
a great job with forsaken
forsaken does sort of get into like
nonsense land once you get to like the
old and sove and the dreaming city and
it kind of becomes harder to follow
but i think the core story of hey
there's this guy you really care about
who's really cool
voice acted by a really charismatic guy
that everybody knows
and he gets killed and you're on a
revenge story i think like that's like
instantly everyone understands what that
is and they're pulled in and i remember
lots of my friends who had
signed off from destiny and said i'm not
gonna play again they came back when
you know their their buddy kate six got
killed like that drew people in and i
think
that's how you focus it right just focus
on small human stories
do the work develop the characters make
people actually care about those people
and i think
you do that in a long enough timeline
and you've got yourself a franchise but
they just haven't
in my opinion put in the work to do that
yet yeah
that's uh i mean your explanation about
sci-fi was really good because i think
asking the question why
is uh it's like fundamentally the most
important human question you can ask
like sci-fi aside like that's just a
philosophical thing
um it's really good that's really good
analogy but um
to your point i absolutely agree with
you i think destiny 1 nailed something
where
you sort of had these bite-sized stories
that you could consume but
i think destiny 2 aside from the blow
problem also suffers from a different
problem which is that
you cannot experience certain things
that have existed in destiny 2 anymore
especially now
with sun setting good points you lose
contact
i talked to my brother about this a lot
when when you boot up
halo 2 or halo 1 or even halo 3.
you experience all of it exactly the way
it was
you know one patch or update three side
right
right that is the way the game was
released and that is and and that's what
it is now
you know live service game different
yeah you know different different era
re-record like we
we went and played destiny one um last
week or earlier this week to play vault
of glass
just to kind of you know get get a feel
for what's going on
and it brought up another discussion on
my brother that i have pretty friggin
with him which is like you can boot up
destiny one
and besides the seasonal events that
happened which you can actually boot up
srl at least
through private matches you can
experience everything that destiny one
uh had to offer is it's not all
fundamentally the same because we had
balance patches and different things got
updated and stuff changed i guess iron
banner as well can never exist or trials
but like
besides those three things you can
experience
everything the way that it was left in
that game destiny 2
especially now with beyond light coming
out you can't do that you cannot
experience the red war
so if you're a player that comes in
right now and as and
a character talks about the red war you
know saladin's like i regret not
fighting in the red war and you're like
what the hell is the red war
what is that like like what's going on
with this and
i i guess maybe the onus is on the
person to be like i should google what
the red war is and find the biff video
where he explains that but that but
i just feel like that doesn't happen
right like there needs to be something
in the game somebody said in chat too
a way to go back and replay cinematics a
way for them to
you know fill in the holes that the game
would have had to be like
you know this content is no longer in
the game but this is story that was in
there and it maybe it's an even an
optional download if they're worried
about the different size of your game
because cinematics can be bigger
i mean halo halo massachusetts
collection does that whereas
yeah each section of the game is an
optional yeah
you don't you don't have to download
multiplayer you can just download its
campaign or vice versa or
i think it even gives you the option for
languages too which is kind of nuts but
yeah like think about the seasonal model
for a second
yeah it's great that finally this year
all the seasons go throughout the whole
year
but you can't play anything from
this the recipient season last year and
that's like a fundamentally
super important season and
like if you just started the game today
right now you have no idea that happened
like that i got it because you're all
the other thing the other thing is that
like because it's week to week
you can't you can't have somebody log on
and finish the arc
and then go okay i get it i played the
taking king you have to get them to come
in
every week and then over like a 30 week
period
or however long seasons last these days
then they complete the arc and like
i think the appetite in the player base
to like do that it's
it's you know the teddies of the world
it's the cogs of the world but there's
only so many of those they're never
gonna
they're never gonna draw in a mass
audience based on like piecemeal stuff
so i think they
there needs to be larger
narrative blocks that can be enjoyed all
at once and hopefully are there for
longer than one season
you guys are on fire because of two
things i wouldn't recognize
acknowledge one i want to shout out
destin
because one thing that he does with his
channel is he
puts the law pieces every week or
any time jesse does anything he puts
those cinematics or narrative beats
in a video right it's funny you guys
have mentioned especially teddy you're
on fire because
shout out to rand outdoor who has
actually called the mass effect 2 team
by the way
but um nice yeah so he is concentrating
he gives me crap he's like destiny's
garbage like he he's been fighting me on
destiny for years
he was like i hate that game i love
bungie but i hate that game it's bad now
whatever
so finally since beyond light and
finally since it's in game pass i'm like
you got no excuse now
it's in game fast it's free come on
right so he's like all right carl go
through all right so we've been
being forte i've been begrudgingly dr
dragging this man in so he's okay so
where do i start i've got to play you
know kind of thing
and now red war is gone right
so he doesn't have that context right
and then
he's like okay well we said well we'll
do forsaken
and then get him to shadow keep so we're
doing forsaken right
and he's like wait a minute ain't that
guy
i saw that guy like aldrin
right in other parts of the game because
he has this the uh we we
gifted him the the battle pass or
whatever it is right so you get to see
crow a little bit so
it's so convoluted for the new player
to jump in to get a true understanding
now don't get me wrong
he enjoyed before saying campaign when
we did it right and i was like look
we're going to include this by doing the
last switch raid
so you can see dramatically where this
thing led to and i said we got to get
you to the dreaming city so you can
understand and that
he loved he was like wow this is
beautiful stuff he's like i cannot he
said i have to admit
but again you know giving him the kind
like i
i'm sitting there having to explain he's
like what does this mean and who's gaul
and
and what is she talking about with the
red ward and all this other stuff
we did the battlegrounds because again
everything's out of sequence
everything's all over the place you know
what i'm saying that's the only
problem i understand why they did the a
la carte method
so that people don't feel left behind to
do the new content
but from a narrative standpoint it sucks
like you don't know what's going on he
doesn't even he was like i got all these
icons i don't know where to start
like should i be doing this first and
then the game doesn't even give you like
a
a sequence of like how you should do it
right
it's still so far behind until the final
point like you said
you made a great point there should be
some type of
kiosk repository something right
because i'm playing forsaken i'm oh man
i don't even remember that cinema
when we did this i don't even remember
how we unlocked the dreaming city i'm
seeing stuff that we did
one time and there's no way to replay it
there's no way to go back to see it and
that's a problem like you you have these
great story beats
and there's just no cohesion especially
for the new guy
and i think that's going to be there
probably still i know the new light and
the
what's his what's your man name and the
cosmodrome the hunter
is here
i know that was a first attempt but
narratively
they are i felt bad i i was actually
questioning my old game i'm like damn
this game is cool but
my man don't really know what's going on
unless i sit there
and have a college course discussion
about the narrative
prior to him missing like that's how i
had to do it destiny forsaken 256 all
right sit down get out your notepads
i think that's kind of always just been
destiny's problem right which is which
is
okay so first of all the new light
experience has gotten a lot better is it
amazing
absolutely not i actually just finished
all the new light stuff a couple weeks
ago
and it's definitely an improvement from
shadow keeps new light uh experience but
to your point like so over the course of
destiny's history i've gotten friends
into the game just like you and and
varying ranges of skill level um
yeah and they all like the game after
they start playing it but then yes but
then you gotta
there's just so much to explain you
don't actually think about how much you
have to explain because we just we just
do it right we're like oh it's the power
leveling okay i gotta do this this and
this
but then you like sit down and actually
explain it to someone and you sound like
a madman
you sound like wow yeah you sound crazy
you're like when i did i did my level
you gotta do this first and then this
and then this but you can't do this hold
on hold on and then and then this but
wait hold on if you get this to drop
then you can't like
it and we for us it's like oh that's
just normal like
we've been doing this for seven years
but for them it's like what the hell i'm
not playing this crap and go back to
borderlands
um and yeah it's just
i don't know how you solve that problem
um
the icon thing that gets everyone i
think everyone starts the game it's like
you
you see that you see the director and
you're like holy crap what am i looking
at
my explaining the season is 30 minutes
long now granted i'm long-winded i get
that
but there's a lot of people that are
well i think that's enough i think you
need to go more i was like and that's
honestly the point was like i try and
condense it down but i know i'm
long-winded so it's like but i try and
go detail of like
here's the power loading this is how
this works this is your power gear this
is the artifact and i try and like
if you're new to the season here's where
you start when you log in if you haven't
played in a while here's where you're
going powerful pinnacle of that stuff
and i'm like
i tried to get it under about 30 minutes
and i was like 32 i'm like i'm done but
i was like
that's a lot to cram in of like this is
how you have to play i'm like
people who get to this be like i haven't
played in a while thank you is like this
is a really good explanation i'm like
i'm glad you enjoyed a 30 minute video
i'm sorry it took me 30 minutes to get
it
like that's not like login kill stuff
level up like
how does that have to be 30 minutes long
but it is
it is i would love to i would love it if
like uh our
our guardians in game experience the
same level of confusion because you
think it was from their perspective
they're waking up
like they died thousands of years ago
and then they wake up and it's like
welcome
you're in the future you're a guardian
and then and then your ghost is like
okay
the thing you need to know about your
vault is we only have so much space
you know i would love it if there was
some sort of tutorial system where it's
just your ghost going all right this is
really gonna throw you for a loop but
energy primary and power ammo
versus kinetic you know it just goes
over that you know
all right so there's this there's this
tincture you're gonna drink and they get
really high and then you're gonna see
it's magical
it's great just just trust me it's gonna
be okay
but it only works
speaking of which he and i were talking
before
um about how uh the crow in a cut scene
last week
not a cutscene it's when you go and you
talk to him he he talks about how
he knows what it's like to be under
control
by another by another like entity and
like
not be able to control your own actions
and i was like wait i thought he was
aldrin and then he died and became a
guardian so he's not supposed to have
any memory
which means like he has memory of like
being older and sov which means
i think it would be great if our
guardian got some memory of who we were
before you know
i was i was talking to e like you know
we worked at like a wendy's
uh you know we were just flipping
patties and we died of cardiac arrest
and then like
you know 70 000 years later we get woke
up in the guardian like i just want to
know who we are because we were on the
freeway in russia right we were going
somewhere
maybe we were visiting russia on
vacation with her family i want a
backstory for our guardian and i want it
to be
very disappointing
i wanted to be just like you were just a
nobody you're just some like
just some guy going home and eating like
a frozen dinner and that was just your
life
before all of this because you wouldn't
know right like
i don't know how far is there a cutoff
point like did you have to die after the
golden age to become a guardian or
are there people who like died in like
1812 and they became guardians like way
later
i want to know the rules they need to be
specific this is my budget this is the
this is the star trek this is the how
this is the star trek this is the star
trek how i just need to know the rules
here
uh really uh okay so question i'm gonna
go through some of the npcs
i want to know what each of you think
they will be or what they used to be in
their old life
before they died before they died i got
it where they got okay
so whoever wants to chime in or if you
got multiple ideas go
uh first one's gonna be saint 14.
oh saint 14 was definitely one of those
like euro trash
disc jockeys you know who like created
like electronic music
that's got to be him right that's cute
a bear wrestler oh there you go
he worked at a circus or something
that's great cocky got anything for him
to say oh my god he just makes me laugh
well
some type of i don't know um instructor
or something like you know
at the gym or something like there you
go like fitness
yeah yeah he's very inviting your old
self carries over like do you
care about your voice and your
personality like was saint gay when he
was
before he was a guardian too and he woke
up and he still had his venus
totally different because then like then
the answer is obvious like cage six was
nathan fillion and then nathan fillion
in real life died and then you came from
six
and that's that's like the obvious
solution like you know like hade is
exactly the ship of theseus is this boat
on one of our fire team chat videos it
was like me ibontis
and paul were all on the show and some
the top comment on that episode was i'm
getting real
shitty theseus vibes from this episode
of fire team shot
because nobody has this thing and i was
just like oh
i love it originals
okay all right we might have to go a
little faster um
shacks
i'm gonna get a football player he was a
linebacker i'm gonna say male stripper
but that's fine
oh my god
for a future music video he was that guy
what did you get for chad shacks uh some
some type of like daycare specialists
i think there's like a lord thing where
he like carries kids around around the
city okay or the kids like frolicks or
something i don't know i'm rolling with
that
that's a good one
librarian yes i get that
shot of a boycott box he gets complete
bookworm
vibes for her yeah i'm with that too my
boy my sophomore year chemist teacher
bottom stamps all day yes
uh asher mirror he's one of my favorite
oh he's one of your favorites i'm sorry
i love you
i love he's always here was bernie
sanders
that's just who he was
i don't know if i can beat that one i
i feel like he was just someone's dad
benedict he's just a wreck
dude yeah like yeah office
you know secret secret life it's
it's weird to think like how much how
much did aldrin saw's personality change
when it became the crow is he
basically the same person because he
seems like he's very different to me so
yeah so i think oh okay first of all
devon's not a guardian so i think he
just was just born a human okay like
existed right but i think with all right
though i think they intentionally had
him rez very close to his death because
i i
as far as i'm aware i don't think that's
ever happened and so
obviously they're exploring like the two
different people
you know ship a thesis thing like
they're basically that's what they're
trying to explore right
that's that's what they're trying to get
it um well i think were we the last
guardian to get resurrected before
aldrin no because lore wise new lights
come every day yeah so we're just um
and there's just a ton of ghosts out
there looking for their guardians
and so we get res basically in a car
that was trying to escape in one of the
shuttles before the collapse happened
is essentially like our guardian's
backstory i think that's what's
happening but
um yeah i wonder i wonder where they'll
go with him specifically because like
obviously he has like some recollection
of something but i think that's not
normal and then anna bray i think is the
only guardian that we know of that
actually dug into her past and found out
who she was prior to becoming a guardian
um which we should according to we are
that would be so good i mean it would
have to have three separate answers
because we haven't awoken an exo yeah
yeah um but according to zavala like he
forbid any guardian
from from digging into their past and
she breaks that rule
so why why i don't know i don't think
they give an explanation
like the high school principal or
something he's lance reddick
he's nice ready yeah yeah he's either
lance reddick in real life
or he was like a cop i could see him
just being a cop i could see the cop
he's got a cops person law enforcement
of some kind definitely last round
who's on the wire yeah that all comes
together
she did like poetry or like those people
who do like art with blood or something
you know she's very gossip
trying to think of anybody else um who's
like
guardian status is the truth if you're a
guardian
yes he's a warlock he is yeah okay yeah
like
light bearer he definitely like didn't
have a job
before like he is my uncle that's funny
he's not crazy uncle he's a husband he's
either like a scam artist or yeah living
on this
with his mom or he did something you
know
mm-hmm a grifter yeah of some kind for
sure
i like smoke worked on a blockbuster guy
he worked at the last blockbuster on
here
he is the manager at the block i'm done
with you
[Laughter]
well that was entertaining um for those
of you guys who have been watching
uh i think we're probably transitioning
out of real destiny chat and into other
things
so as long as these gentlemen want to
stay around and chat um
as for the twab grandmasters are here
iron banners next week
please be a decent human being and by
the tweet while
trials is back did i miss anything on
the twab you got that
tomorrow sorry you didn't get eyes
tomorrow play next week
drop rate which we didn't talk about but
i was still haven't gotten
that yeah i'm acknowledging you know the
whole account thing versus you know the
individual player aspect right teddy
actually yeah so one and one character
this whole time so it didn't affect me i
just didn't feel
unlucky yeah um so they explained they
explained that the problem with this
specific instance but i i we didn't talk
about the uh the blog they put out i
think last week that was like going into
detail on um another
density and all that stuff yeah they
talked about the teleportation part
yeah uh uh yeah well i forgot i forgot
the blog
that wasn't a separate no no they put
out a completely separate blog it was
like a tech blog that they started
to basically explain how bugs work
and they got like a designer or someone
to explain it and i i've been asking for
this for
years like i i used to binge their gdc
talks i just wanted to understand
how certain things worked in destiny and
that's the closest i could get without
actually talking to them um i'm i should
look up the blog now but like
uh yeah the blog it went into some bug
explanation and i just like that and
they did this in the in the swap for
this eyes of tomorrow
um thing i i just i when they explain
things yeah when they when they explain
stuff
this is a fundamental life philosophy i
have if you give people the opportunity
to understand something or to
ask the why and then come to a
conclusion themselves they will
generally be more accepting of that
conclusion even even if they maybe
disagree with it
um it's just human nature for that to
happen so
bungie's kind of always been very
tight-knit about like how certain things
work or why certain things happen and
i as a person that just likes to ask
those questions and i'm not alone in
this regard
like just tell me if you just explain to
me how it works i will be
way less upset about like 99 of the
things that i'm mad about in this game
um and so i'm happy that they're
starting that finally
do i want more absolutely give me the
numbers give me the hard
math that i can you know they probably
just don't like the answers to some of
the
y's you know and it's one of those
probably i i guess but like
yeah it's just you gain nothing by
telling somebody the why if the y is
like
sorry you know it's just kind of mean
that's what you guys were talking about
when it comes to um the teleporting
enemies it was just the fact that there
were literally too
many in you know enemies in the game it
was like kind of a brief summary
like to sum it up and it's like that
begs the question of like
okay so we had the d1 strikes that were
limited in certain ways now we have more
enemy density and you're kind of
breaking your game
again these lead me to the questions of
what the next three years are going to
be like
because it does make me wonder of like
how
much they can do within you know the
bounds of the systems they've built
so i will be very curious to see
honestly what comes over
this giant revelation that is which
queen is it all story and the mechanics
feel the same or can they
you know when do they start pushing next
gen over the next three years like
is the destiny 3 whatever you know post
the 10 year saga is that our next gen
game
and this is still going to maintain the
same systems over the next three years i
know they do some behind the scenes
stuff
but we also still hear about the
spaghetti code and again
enemy density and a strike like was
breaking stuff and you're like
how much longer do things continue to
last how big of
how big big of a break has to happen
before you know we see something like
yeah we're gonna try and limp along or
we have a big fix in incoming and i just
kind of wonder when
some big system is going to change so
because people are loving the enemy
density
but if it also breaks the game it's kind
of a problem yeah absolutely i mean you
got that and then combine that
with the inbound you know cross cross
plays coming
yeah you know there's a lot of there's a
lot of systems they got to deal with
obviously we've seen them
struggle with this whole trials thing
with the rejoining game
and then um shout out you know dylan
having to try to explain why it was such
a nasty bug
and why they didn't want to remove
joining completely because they said
initially it was going to affect all
crucible modes
all other activities i thought all other
activities yeah it was a big thing so
you know i i with teddy though i still
am about
you know the explanation you know
because the more detail you give me with
that
the more like you said it's humiliating
the more understanding i'm going to be
to you but if you try to
disrespect my intelligence by acting
like it is you're so above
giving me the reason why you can't
explain this or the percentage of why
things are
operating in the way they are then it's
just gonna we're gonna hear the the
bungo
comments you know saying like good old
bunga here they go
yeah well there's missing information
like you fill in the gaps right and now
for us as like
hardcore players you know we have some
specifically like oh i mean all of us
have talked to them at various points
but like
you know there's certain things that
like we just know inherently about the
game or how it functions or maybe we ask
them something and so you can kind of
sometimes piece things together but when
you have that like gap
in you know how the drop how how drops
work industry like that's not even a
thing that's
ever been explained and maybe they don't
want to reveal the magic formula of rng
or whatever right but like
just just having that like every other
mmo does it
so i don't i it's just to me it's kind
of weird why they don't they just have a
different philosophy
they're very close to vest they're very
analytic driven you know and for
whatever reason even when it comes down
to
and trust me i love being a sandbox
update right
but even when it comes down to you know
we buffed auto rifles
you know but sometimes they why like how
much like what is it in relation that
the specifics like
you know they're very afraid sometimes
to just
give you what that is and it it's it's
very interesting you know they're
community members who love the followers
the cool guys like the drewski's the
deep pvp piece and the mercury's this
spreadsheet people like when you go
we can't even see all the stats on our
guns yeah you can't see the aim assist
you can't see the recoil direction
it's literally in the game and people
data mine that with like dim light.gg
gunsmith right
it's there but it's not like hey this
has like literally if in game is like
hey your
recoil direction's a 60. it's going to
veer to the right
if you throw the counterbalance mod on
there it's going to make it vertical if
that was told in game
the average player would understand okay
i know why this mod makes sense
right now they're just like i think it
makes my gun feel better
right and you know where the worst
offender is in my opinion
is they introduce this cool thing with
the artifact right
you know i shouldn't have to wait for a
fallout video
to to understand what sundering whatever
it
is
right like yeah like and then like the
game
another thing like they'll have these
perks you know they don't
tell you how like how you proc it what
you have like
it's sometimes the very vague generic
flavor text
of an explanation is just so generic
that i literally got to go watch a video
to truly
understand like even that same perk
sundering lip it doesn't even tell you
in game that it's proc like i have to
watch yeah
you see like fade on the weapon yeah and
i'm like
you don't even know what it's doing you
know and then i realized how powerful
this thing is
i'm like wow this thing is a is a 20 or
whatever 30 buff from distance
that for the most part adds on to the
whole debuffing thing that we thought
they stopped
remember they was like hey whatever the
strongest debuff is the one we're going
to take
as the highest ratio and the other ones
are going to be eliminated they're not
going to you know take that
take into account and i'm learning like
this stuff and again like they they do
sometimes they do a horrible job of
truly sometimes understanding
yeah you know i'm being nice to being
nice you know but
especially that final column where a lot
of those
cool very game defining artifact mods
that go on your class thing
and you're like yo i don't want to
invest all of this money for the glimmer
to re reset the artifact
as well as the choice right because
you're picking all these cool things
and you want to make a good decision and
this thing doesn't really explain
what it is for me to pick it you know so
they still got to do
a way better job with explanation of
these things and mechanics that they are
they themselves are trying to introduce
to get us to play fantastic
rampage rampage you literally don't know
unless you go look it up
how much of a percentage ads from one
two and three stacks multi-kill clip
radio
nothing is told it's just like yeah
rampage does more damage
how much yeah they i was like is there
an intention that some of this is vague
so the average player is like well i get
a little more damage here
this one feels pretty good we'll
multi-clip i gotta reload then how many
i killed but it's like they don't know
one's up to like 50 percent the other
one's over here like seven
they just know they get some more damage
and it's a feel so is it the vagaries
that keep
the people who aren't listening to this
podcast like excited about a new weapon
or i got rampaging let's be honest
it's good for the content creators it's
good for us
or is like is i honestly cannot picture
bungie making their game to say
hey all these content creators are gonna
be able to dive in and figure this stuff
out
like some people literally be like all
right i'm gonna go hardcore after
x weapon and do a video that's like i
cannot imagine that being a part of
their business discussion
if it is they are a lot nicer to the
community than i thought they were
but generally it's like i don't think
that's how they do a business it's some
choice to keep things vague and it's
like
yeah you go and you play out writers i'm
like you can pull up your character
screen and i don't down to the decimal
percentage how much more weapon life
leach i got by putting something on and
i'm like
why is that stuff have to be hidden in
the game it's so strange to me
i mean it's definitely um it's part of
their like core philosophy of making
communities right and so
i think some of the not explaining
things comes from
this idea that oh if we don't explain it
someone will figure it out or make a
video about it and that
that builds that community and that you
know they have their community and that
also
builds the destiny community as a whole
um and i think that's just inherently
baked into their business model because
halo basically created that right like
halo is what made that
um there's some obviously other games
followed but it took i mean if you
really think about it took a really long
time for other games to get that same
level of
uh interaction and and cult following if
you will
where people make these like crazy
videos explaining stuff
and destiny from the very beginning was
just kind of like that so i mean plus
two agility
like destiny one like what did that even
mean we didn't know what that meant for
years until
somebody figured out oh it's a ten point
scale
on your one and plus two just happens to
give you two extra
but like that is not communicated
anywhere in the game at any point
anywhere like i think someone like did
like pixel measurements
or something yeah but you know that's
just like one crazy example but there's
a lot of stuff in this like that so i
think that is inherently baked into the
business model of destiny that they want
you know the fallouts or the the cool
guys or whoever to make these
elaborate videos where they explain this
this thing
do i want it in the game and could it be
better absolutely like that's that's not
even a question
um but we're seven years in like
i'm i'm done asking just no no you're
making a good point it could totally be
that
it just last what i'll just say just
only reason why there's some frustration
with me again i gotta
keep hopping on the artifact which these
are you know these are big investments
like that those last two perk choices
for me
are something i really think about i
want to i really maximize
the efficiency of my build and i don't
want to make a wrong choice
you know what it is teddy i find myself
resetting my goddamn artifact so
it's just stupid that i couldn't
comprehend so much that was my bungie
please let no that was was it mine
was it my bunch of blues yeah like let
me just unlock the whole damn thing
why not like you you're gonna get
different varieties at the same time
anyway right
like you can't quit more than two anyway
in each column so it's like there's no
reason not to
i might unlock like they're gonna make
you pick different like meta weapons for
the season anyway god forbid i get a
little
extra dexterity and stuff here anyway so
it's like i still do not see why that
requires
i mean after playing outriders and you
can reset your whole damn skill tree and
i'm like i can't reset my artifact for a
few months come on yeah
just yeah whole tree and borderlands
yeah it's like
why does it cost so much it should not
be it's a temporary thing anyway it
should not be like prohibitive
yeah that was that was my last rant i
had to get that yeah
what are your three favorite star wars
characters
oh finish it strong daddy you go first
or you can do one and one and bounce
back and forth ooh
okay probably obi-wan
at the top um i think mostly because i
kind of
i kind of see myself as that like i've
just always been an old soul
and so um but he's also just a deeply
flawed character and i think that's what
makes him
good but he strives to do the right
thing
um that's why i'm really excited for the
ob1 series as well but uh i'd have to
think about the other two obi-wan was
the first one that came to my mind i i
mean i wouldn't probably not places in
any order just kind of
just like top three shots out of there
this is sophie's choice i know
so that's the fun part
which franchise isn't better well you
think while you think which franchise is
better star wars or fast and furious
uh star wars oh that's not hard why is
fascism
why is this fascinating i just watched
the fierce movies you're editing a wiki
though
fast and furious is okay i'm going to
pivot
this will let you guys think this will
let you guys multiply fast and furious
is one of those things where you didn't
do trouble
yeah yeah sorry someone in the
comments was saying yoda um which is
which is a
a very good choice yoda um so
fast and furious is fascinating to me
because
it's sort of one it has it has a few
different things that i think
are are great one it's got like this
cast of charismatic people that like
i unironically think that like vin
diesel is one of the greatest actors of
our generation like
he he just drips charisma in a way that
i think
is is like improbable especially coming
from a guy who looks like him i think
that it's just like
he there's just something about him like
you want to see it and i think that cast
it it represents america in a in a lot
of really important ways one
it's like diverse like they were one of
the first franchises to have just a ton
of diversity front center
and you can see that reflected in how
well they've done internationally their
movies
rake in a lot of money not because they
do yeah not because they do inc
like better than anywhere else in
america it's because their international
appeal because of
what the cast looks like i think that
that's hugely important and it's kind of
a reflection of something that i think
is uniquely american and that i
really uh enjoy um and then on top of
that it's got
um themes that i think are you know you
can kind of laugh at them like the kind
of silliness that that
first brings but at its core the the the
the
thing that fast furious tries to teach
you i would argue
is that doing the right thing and doing
the lawful thing aren't always the same
and i think that is an important thing
for people to learn and
it's from the first movie all the way on
that this like
civil disobedience and kind of kind of
deciding where you stand
and not always standing with authority
and kind of that that the way that that
plays i think is important for people to
learn in
increasingly authoritarian or at least
like you know people who are kind of
being
obsequious to authority uh i think that
that's really important to learn
um there's the family thing somebody put
in the comments like that's
an obvious one and they do kind of just
like say it in in the
in you know do they just say the word
without you know sometimes
showing it i think is is one of the
failings of the of the
franchise but the idea that these people
from different walks of life who have
little in common except for their creed
is important um
i think i think i've mentioned this to
some of you maybe not on the show but
like
i'm a game master i i i do like role
playing with dice
uh at my house once a month it's not dnd
uh but it's okay it's games it's role
playing games like roll
type no so so i do like there's a star
wars rpg where you can just create
characters in the star wars universe and
igm
that um and i also write my own rpgs and
i'm i'm writing a fast and furious rpg
called ride or die uh a fast and furious
rpg where you create characters and it's
kind of got this uh
this really interesting mechanic where
if you're bringing a new player into the
group
they have to be the bad guy for their
first session because that happens in
every fast and furious movie where like
true
the bad guy comes and then after you
meet him they kind of join the family so
that's like
these interesting mechanics like that um
and and then
you know the other thing i love about it
is that i was never into
anime until i watched fast and furious
fast and furious is is an anime it's a
live-action anime it follows all the
rules of anime
it has the uh the power creep trope if
you guys are familiar with power creep
it's
a term that is often used in anime for
when people start off and they're just
like normal and then eventually they're
goku and god ii form or whatever with
the sparkly blue hair
um and and uh fast and furious has that
which i just think is
fascinating i think they're the only
live-action example of an anime like
it's just a it's a it's a weird crazy
thing and it comes from
i think the mind of justin lin who i i
think is a is a genius he's the director
of
tokyo drift and he's sort of kind of
been the the the guy guiding the
franchise on its path in modern days and
kind of uh directing it that way i
think that he's a genius the way he
tells stories is
so unique and interesting and something
we haven't seen in movies before
and they're just not afraid to to go
there and to go
they kind of build trust with you so
that when in the eighth film
there's a zombie army of cars flying
down new york you kind of just go
okay fine like you've earned it like
you've made so many films
and you know i like these characters and
it's kind of like to what i was saying
earlier why
in sci-fi i care about the the why more
than the
the hows or the what that you get in
like hard sci-fi like star trek
and i think fast and furious really is
good at putting aside the how and the
what
and focusing on the why like why are you
doing it and what's like the human story
here
and that like as long as you have that
and you nail it like nothing else really
matters so
um i just i i just love the the
the like carefree style and the way that
they draw from things like anime and
the the morals that they try to teach
you are right and it's just the further
you dig into it it's one of those things
where
i think i saw you know obviously i saw
all the fast and furious
when they were out and we were kind of
watching them when we were younger
and i think when five came out and it
was just like this unexpected heist film
oh yeah and kind of really went over the
top
i kind of started to dive in a little
bit more and the more i
i dug in the more i was just like this
this fast and furious thing like it's
kind of like surface level it's like
popcorn turn your brain off movie
right but the deeper you go the crazier
it gets like
i don't you guys probably don't know
this but there's like this crazy theory
that justin lynn has been working
characters from fast and furious into
his other movies
uh justin lin did a a like indie film
called better luck tomorrow and the
character that plays
han is in that movie and his character's
name is han
and he's like a chain smoker and then in
fast and furious the character han
played by the same actor
he's always eating snacks and giselle uh
gal gadot's character
uh references the fact that he's
snacking all the time because he used to
be like a chain smoker so
there's like these layers where the
deeper you go into the wiki you find
stuff that's
not strictly fast and furious because
maybe it's part of the universe
it kind of gets weird and uh there's
stuff like that that's like
less like the the one of the things i
love about fast and furious uh like
something that i bring up a lot when i
talk to people about it is uh
sorry i'm like i'm like cracking out
right now i'm just kind of talking to
you guys
yeah yeah um ludacris is in fast and
furious
he plays ted parker and uh he's he start
he starts to appear in the movies
starting in the second film too fast too
furious
but in the first fast and furious film
they're at vin diesel's house at dominic
toretto's house
and there's a house party going on and
in the party
there's a ludicrous song playing right
and so
in that world ludacris is a person and
he's an artist who makes music
and then also there's a guy who looks
exactly like him
his name is parker and no one talks or
mentions like dude
an awful lot like ludicrous the artist
that apparently canonically exists in
this world
and there's there's actually multiple
examples of that in like media like
marvel has that problem where samuel
jackson
is in marvel as uh you know the the
leader of the
uh avengers initiative but he's also in
star wars which is referenced
in marvel like spider-man references the
star wars films
you know in in marvel so then it's like
why does nobody go up to him and be like
dude you look
just like the same accident like
there's like these these great areas
right like is this
meta or like that's did the events of
the marvel universe make it so that
the original star wars films were made
but the prequels didn't happen
and you know you know because the
prequels aren't referenced just the
original
story so maybe the prequels are never
happening big enough to dig you out of
this rabbit hole
give me one star wars character on the
top of your list
yeah yeah you had enough time to think
now yeah i think i
am going to be rather cliche and go with
yoda
i i i mean it's it really is a sophie's
choice for me it's really hard for me to
choose these characters because each of
them to me
yeah each of them means something to me
in a completely different way i think my
favorite star wars character period
better than yoda is emperor palpatine
there was something about as a kid
seeing
uh the emperor appear he was in some of
the earlier films but he really didn't
show up in force until episode six
return of the jedi about seeing that guy
and seeing the way that
he exuded power and i was scared of him
as a kid and i kind of liked that and i
think
there's something to be said about like
the guy holding the leash and that
mastermind thing that is done so well in
star wars and
unfortunately palpatine in my opinion is
one of those characters that has become
progressively less cool the longer that
they've developed him
star wars has this like very weird
slider where some characters it's like
the more you know the cooler they are
yeah like darth maul went from being to
me like a lot of people thought he
looked cool whatever but just being a
nothing character they throw them away
like
to being like actually legitimately
having a great arc
if you want to see one star wars
lightsaber battle
that you probably haven't seen unless
you're teddy uri that you should
go watch the the darth maul obi-wan
lightsaber fight in star wars rebels
it's like a three-minute scene you can
find on youtube
and it is the single best lightsaber
fight
and not for the reason you expect it's
for the exact opposite reason of why the
phantom menace duel of fates lightsaber
fight is great
um and i'm sure teddy can fanboy with me
on that one like that scene
is just that scene is so with
zombies and subtext and like all these
different histories and it just it ends
in like this perfect moment
i'm working through his art
so yeah i'm with you there i like rebels
more than clone wars people make fun of
me for that but
uh i you know clone wars does a ton
of like work and redeeming darth maul as
like a character you care about
it doesn't get all the way there though
it kind of did in the more recent season
that they did after rebels but
it gets it gets close and then rebels
just takes it to like next level like
like darth maul is like a character i'm
proud to have in star wars rather than
one i was kind of ashamed of because he
was just like this dumb you know spike
spike haired demon who gets sliced in
half and then you don't hear from him
anymore but
uh yeah i would say probably emperor
palpatine in spite of myself because
he's had the opposite effect of darth
maul where he got less cool the longer
they expanded on him
uh a reverse maul if you will maybe i'll
coin that term
um and uh stop trying to make make fetch
happen
yeah right but i i still think that like
uh
what he did for the original films for
me anyway was was huge
um and i i think that actor's talented
he's like an over actor but in a way
where he really makes it work and owns
it and
um yeah i i just i like palpatine teddy
um if you didn't steal your order
because yoda the do or do not try quote
is something that i like really live by
uh i think when i first heard that um i
think it's an episode
five right um yeah episode
uh and then uh it's he was i played last
we'll caliber four which had yoda in it
as well
and he says that a lot in that game and
uh
i don't know i just i to me that's like
it's such a it's such a simple
philosophy to have but it's so powerful
at the same time like if you if you have
that mindset of
of trying something you're already
setting up yourself for failure
um now failure is a different topic that
you know i don't think failure is
inherently bad but uh and
yoda teaches this greed uh yeah
and yeah the failure thing he he is he
also did it
ryan johnson did it in um in the last
jedi where he talks about how
you know i told you didn't listen to me
t pass on what you've learned and
what you've learned includes your
failure i did uh i did comedy for like
10 years i was i was a comedian like
growing up just you know in my
neighborhood i did stand up and improv
comedy and that's like
yeah i taught comedy for a number of
years and that's like one of the
like most important principles of comedy
is that like failure is a learning
experience you have to fail to get
better
nobody's just good at comedy right away
you get up and you try jokes and you
find out
where the line is and you find out what
you're good at doing and where your
strengths and weaknesses are and you get
better but like
failure is a is instrumental in like
growth and it's something you should be
proud of and you wear every failure with
a badge of honor
uh when i started doing like improvised
comedy i was so bad at it
that my teammates called me boo bucket
that was my nickname because i got booed
off stage so often
and uh yeah i've been scarred man i went
through the ringer
like the first two years i did comedy i
was just awful like
just cringe-worthy i i'll be like in the
shower some days and i'll think of
something that happened to me when i was
new at comedy and
i'll have to like scream it out of my
body because it gets into my brain and
makes me upset
um but yeah this episode is going to be
titled the bottom stamp in the boo
bucket
honestly like teddy like there's certain
people you connect with
like you just know like teddy i we
connected really early about like the
philosophy of star wars and the things
we care about
cog i kind of got that with you when we
first started talking and it seems like
we kind of had like similar upbringings
from like neighborhoods that mirrored
each other and there's just people you
connect with and i think
star wars is so important because it
helps people connect in a way that
especially for nerds they often have a
hard time connecting in a
in a in a meaningful way that's a good
important way to do that
that i think is so yeah like i mean just
this is like a super tangible like
personal story so i graduated high
school in 2012 which
is almost 10 years ago but uh at that
point star wars was still not really
that accepted as like this this thing
right the sequel trilogy had not even
been announced at that point i think
disney just bought star wars
and that was a big deal right and i
always had a star wars shirt on
uh everyone knew i was super nerdy and i
would say i got teased and made fun of
but
i'm a pretty confident person inherently
so it didn't bother me that much
but i do remember like people it wasn't
it wasn't cool to like star wars and i'm
not trying to like say i'm hipster and i
like star wars before all you people but
like
i was also born on star wars days so
maybe i kind of do but uh
it it it's such an important
thing that i think people and they've
talked about this now in recent years
with you know
celebration different things like that
it's such an important thing to so many
people because it helps
connect people and humanize things like
this the stories of star wars are
universal and and
you know other mediums copy that and
that's fine right like it's
and it's important there are certain
people you just me and you just know
right like as soon as we started talking
travis i was like
this this guy gets it like it's like it
gets me man
we're we're star wars fans uh it's the
same with with cog and e2 like there's
just certain people you meet and you
just you just kind of know it but
um yeah there's the yo yoda yoda's my
answer because
try to set up perfect like failure and
it's just a life lesson that i've
learned from my parents like it's
what failures are such an important
lesson that that you hold with you and
and you learn more from failure than
success
and if you can extrapolate that then
then you you can go far
you can you can make it so using the
force
and my final one for the admiral thrawn
that's number three for me
admiral thrawn i have to go with a uh
with like a a
side character that's not like in any of
the main stuff yet although he
definitely was like they've mentioned
him
and uh yeah said show thrawn is like
the perfect i tend to like villains and
shows i kind of root for them it's like
a weird part of my personality yeah
i'm like oh i want them to do well um oh
by the way cog we have to talk about uh
blood
or spartacus too because i saw that you
like that show
yes yeah i'm also i'm writing a uh an
rpg uh that's like a
a based on ancient rome and it's like
features like gladiators is like the
players all play like a school of
gladiators that are traveling around and
competing in the games and stuff so
bye at some point i have to get you guys
over here to play rpgs with me but uh
yeah
yeah admiral thrawn like he's the
ultimate uh villain because he
uses his brain and he's like the
opposite of darth vader or
like a darth maul where he's not really
a physical physical threat but he's also
not a threat in the same way that
palpatine is like palpatine
is very controlled but he's like he's a
different type of danger
like you know he's dangerous even though
he doesn't do it and thrawn is kind of
like
intentionally not dangerous but he his
he's just so good at maneuvering that
like
you know before he even enters the room
that he's like
five days ahead of you in terms of like
where he's at mentally and
they i i would love to see how people
write for him because it's one of those
things where like
i really respect people who are able to
like okay
five episodes ago thrawn was already
here so we need to justify
everything he does so that when it gets
to the end you're like oh
like that's what he was planning to do
and the people who write him
are really good at doing it there
there's some um there's some
like franchises that are really good at
doing that like uh
phoenix wright if any of you guys are
into the ace attorney series like
i have no idea how they create cases in
phoenix right because by the time you
get to the end of the case
it's so different from where it was at
the beginning that you're like you can
scarcely remember how you got there um
but yeah i'd love to see how so yeah
admiral thrawn is number three for me
that's a good pick
he's a good character i'm trying between
darth vader and ahsoka
uh i mean darth vader is like like the
kind of the obvious choice but uh i
think i like it so because she operates
in
in the gray area and that's that's sort
of me i kind of see myself as that like
i tend to
i tend to very closely walk the line
with a lot of stuff and
um but for good right you do it
is gray i think she's actually more
light side than the jedi claim to be i
think the jedi are grey
and i think that she doesn't fit in with
the jedi because she's so
optimistic and refuses to compromise
that's i thought
about that actually i thought about that
a lot especially because of well i don't
want to spoil it but in
the new thing that she was in recently
uh
that that kind of it kind of got that
vibe um i was like oh i think she's
ascended
beyond what what the previous iteration
was
but uh yeah that's a different topic
i'll go with soca why not why not
character well i was like i had to do
that because they were on here together
and like if there if there are bro fist
bumps in the world of star wars these
two
are the epitome of that on twitter so
yeah my clunky i got mine my understand
was fraud so
mines is our ginger and
i'm like to me he represents me i'm late
to the whole party i was so young when
my mom
took me to the original i don't remember
anything as i'm old and i was actually
taken to the movie theater
at a young age when the original trilogy
trilogy came out and all that stuff
vague memories so i never really
connected with star wars
that much but my man favreau man i i
i loved i i came into mandalorian late
and begrudgingly i was just like
you know i watched always i respect it i
understand what it represents
and there's a lot of cool aspects to it
but i just
never was that invested but
the mandalorian character kind of
represents me like this outsider
that's like watching all this other
great stuff going around and then
finding my way within the universe and i
just love the emotional connection with
you know
almost like this parenting you know kind
of thing and and taking care of girl
cool and all that stuff
it had some some moments it was some tea
journey i was like okay
i get it and i get the the fun aspect it
almost felt like
a quest game like in the beginning like
him going to try to find help the child
and
you know him going to this plan it felt
like a game and i was like this is cool
they actually modeled it after after
video game design
that was the thing that they did that's
why it really resonated i'm like yo this
is like
what's next step for the quest okay what
you got to do and you know that kind of
thing and
i i hate to be disrespectful i know you
guys are loyal historians
but in my opinion that theme
is one of the greatest the mandalorian
theme song
i don't know what it does to me it it it
evokes pure emotion like i i feel that
cool character so
the mandalorian for me is just it's
amazing i love that with that thing i
listen to the whole thing the storyboard
at the end with the little art and all
that yes i'm with y'all
y'all got me in john fowler you can
thank me the casual
for now being completely invested on
where they go
based on that character so so watch
clone wars that's what i was told yeah
because because now
because you'll have a much deeper
appreciation for what happens in the
mandalorian and rebels too
because all three of those shows are
inexplicably linked um
not because they were made by the same
people but um
there's there's so much that goes on in
those shows that doesn't necessarily
it kind of affects the greater universe
for star wars but at the same time it
also doesn't and that like
it doesn't matter that it doesn't either
like this characters because they have
so much more time to breathe and grow
um and my counterpoint cog is maybe
don't watch the clone wars
i don't think it's for everyone i really
like it but i think it's okay if people
are on the periphery of star wars
and personally i think you're way too
cool to watch a lot of star wars it
makes sense why you didn't watch it when
you were a kid
you didn't need that uh teddy and i and
actually all of us
grew up in an era where like nerds still
had shame you know now they're very
proud of it but like when i was a kid
like if you were a nerd you got beat on
and like i got beat on
back i grew up in oakland in the 90s
like it was
brutal it wasn't cool to talk about that
stuff yeah you're right
you're right yeah absolutely and shout
out to my man matt don't match the truth
he out there singing the song
that chime with the charm hit it
that was the greatest most epic thing
i've ever heard i watched the making of
it by the guy who did it oh my god i
think that thing's amazing
i downloaded that song on beatsaber
is part of my workout when i do cardio
yeah i'm gonna buy you like workout
clothes that look like the mando armor
yeah under armour compression like they
did for me
bro i will buy all of the merch and your
mask is just the mandolin
[Music]
yeah i'll listen to battle the heroes
sometimes while i'm walking which trap
travis knows what that is but
great great yeah that's just an all-time
favorite when
yeah like there's a lot of songs that
you could there's also really bad ones
to be fair star wars does have a few
stinkers in there especially
[Laughter]
same notes again all right let's go yeah
i can't justify that one
that's good well as we are at about
three hours i'm sure everybody has live
food and other things that they've got
to get to
um we can wrap this thing up but
honestly thank you both gentlemen one
travis for working with me on the
logistics of the surprise
the nerd ventures we've ruined it
completely um
but i did want to uh just ask you
gentlemen um
just you know as we wrap up the episode
anything else you guys want to say
thoughts on destiny weren't sad thoughts
on
if there's any other random franchise
you got a couple minutes if just what
you're working on where people can find
you
if they just want to hit you in your dms
about star wars like teddy you were the
og guest so we'll start with you sir the
floor is yours to start
um yeah i'm i'm for for the first time
in a long time i am
very optimistic about destiny's future
um
usually i'm very cautious optimistic or
even pessimistic as most people call it
i like to think i'm a realist but yeah
people see that as pessimism um it's
just what pessimists
say describe themselves when they're
being
i mean uh
but it yeah like obviously you know we
talked about some of it but there's a
lot going on with destiny and
we're still in a pandemic world and so
it's kind of it's the escape right and
so
it's nice to have that and i'm glad that
banjo is still able to
facilitate the the game that we love and
uh yeah
as far as stuff you can follow me on
twitter at teasing
teddy i think eupontis has it on on the
stream um
you can shoot your star wars or destiny
questions at me i'll probably respond
with some patrolling gif
or something or or either like a very
long explanation that you definitely
didn't want to read but that's
that's up to you um quit longer
uh occasionally i post stuff for ign
here and there but uh you probably never
know it's me and i'll never tell you
it's me so
uh other than that uh go ahead travis i
mean the floor is yours
yeah uh i'm also extremely optimistic
about destiny i think we talked about
some stuff that like
i'm worried about like the storytelling
future and if they can kind of branch
out in a way where
it doesn't progressively just isolate
more and more people um except for the
hardcore but
especially for the people who are
hardcore like it's extremely exciting
obviously bungie has stuff planned the
tweets of
of their own employees being super
excited is just so like heartwarming to
me and
i think they're making a real effort and
planning out the future and we know that
they're obviously doing good as a
business and
i think people probably underestimate
how much of a shift it was to move away
from activision because
you know i i worked with bungie when
they were under activision and their
just whole business was different they
had people that
you know were instrumental to the team
that stayed with activision after the
split and
and you know hiring those resources and
getting your team all on the same page
takes a really long time
um and and i think they're probably now
at
a place where they really are starting
to feel like they're controlling their
own destiny
and definitely pun intended and uh i
think i think that's really good for
them and i think it's even better for us
so i'm just really excited
um you can find me on ign.com uh
i i post reviews previews articles uh
every now and again
um am i working on a review right now no
i'm not so
yeah look look out for one of those in
the near future i'm sure
uh and then you can also find me uh on
twitter at thai guy travis and on fire
team chat
with an episode every other friday
including this friday we
recorded a show uh right before i hopped
on with you guys so that's
already live um it's paul myself and a
return
of the the destiny uh himself
makes a appearance so um that's really
good
and if nothing else if you if you don't
care about fire team chat at least go to
the youtube video and watch the first 30
seconds because we are
starting to do uh cold open sketches uh
oh
and uh that's something that we started
when destiny went out and we've decided
we're gonna continue to do it so i'm
playing around with the format
a little bit now that i've uh had a
chance to kind of uh
monkey around while destin was was on
paternity leave um so yeah really
excited about that
um yeah and thanks for having me on i
just want to give
before you guys do your outro a uh a big
thank you
and an applause to cog and ebontis
because you guys are uh
are awesome uh the fact that you do this
show
every week uh even fire team chat
couldn't handle it every week
uh at a certain point now we're doing
every other week just because it's kind
of
brutal granted we're at 595 episodes but
you know it's it's a
an uphill track this sort of stuff isn't
easy content creation is super hard
super draining um on yourselves and your
personal lives and
and it just takes a lot out of you and
sometimes you end up like cog sleeping
during the day and waking up at night
time and just having a
a completely unacceptable lifestyle
and i think i think that deserves praise
and thanks so
thank you guys absolutely yeah thank you
it's always a pleasure
always a pleasure man yeah i mean i'll
jump right in oh man look man this is a
this is a pleasant surprise
it was it's alright i was already hyped
for teddy because we haven't had we had
to keep
our tradition of 21 episodes teddy you
know how we do it yeah
it's your podcast easter egg yeah it's
literally math like he
brought it to my this is how analytical
teddy he brought that to buy diesel you
know
i've been on every exact 21 episode i'm
like i had no idea about that like and i
looked
at the episode history it was it was
coincidence too yeah
yeah it just felt that way so when it
was coming up he was like you know i got
to be hard and we were like evie you're
like yeah yeah
all right so we'll schedule the next one
out and uh you know five months we'll
see five months in a week we'll see then
yeah so it just had to happen so salute
to that and then obviously
we get the ultimate cameo the ultimate
guest
character you know what's the new
challenge reveal
yes the reveal added added in post
just like mcclunkey uh itself so
trying on the tradition i love the
memphis a huge fan of you man i mean
you guys are killing it and i loved how
you took the reigns
obviously with the destiny doing the
family thing but you held it down sir i
was
watching the episodes i was like look
man guys talented
tremendous energy tremendous passion i
love the synergy what you guys doing
over there and i always appreciate
the love yeah man you know me at lord
cognito on twitter
i'm a podcast on sunday this sunday we
will have
uh kind of up-and-coming content great
his name is assemble really very
talented from uh
from canada you should check out for
this guy man he's kind of in our space
which is like
gaming nerd culture like gaming you know
movies comics that kind of stuff i think
he's super talented a lot of people
don't know about him so
we like to give us some new upcoming
content creators a shot so check us out
we appreciate the support
also got a plug loads of gaming.net
appreciate y'all vindi i've been doing
real i mean the love for us as a new
site has been really good
appreciate the articles and stuff like
that being retweeted and of course that
last word man you know how we do it
getting back talking that destiny
talking that outriders now it seems to
be picking up steam
you know and um and game pass and stuff
like that and uh
you're huge huge huge i mean i've got
people coming up to me
asking me a thousand questions about it
i direct them to you
you know and what's going on with you
but um yeah it's just been a huge week
in gaming and all that good stuff and uh
yeah we appreciate the support but yeah
this is a fun episode
we got to do more of this i love this
whole four panel thing again it's like
the avengers the team coming together
man
that's right [ __ ] it's fun absolutely
this is good i like i need to talk to
you about xbox at some point we're both
yes huge we gotta talk we gotta talk
definitely i gotta get you back in the
realm as well
at some point for sure i don't know if i
can top what any of these gentlemen said
um so all i can say is thank you all
for being part of this fun episode thank
you chat thank you for all of you guys
that listened on audio
whether it be spotify itunes google play
wherever you listened
thank you guys if you do make it to the
end somehow i'm gonna start saying this
in the beginning so it actually ever
hits but
if you make it to the end and you enjoy
you know do the
review on itunes follow the podcast on
spotify all that stuff always helps
biggest thing for you to review this
episode we will give you a resounding
top stamp
i'll give you a heartfelt mcclunky
[Laughter]
nice uh but yeah for me ivantas you know
it's like
um outriders literally about two weeks
away so i'm gonna be
definitely diving hardcore into that
lucky enough to be ambassador which
you know that's kind of like free
marketing for them but honestly
it's just been kind of cool i think for
me
like it's just been cool to see the
progress and i'm happy to be part of a
game
that i get to be excited about as
opposed to
hey there was one of the game i applied
for code i'm not gonna say it is i got
it and then when it came around to time
to play
yeah it didn't quite have the same feel
so it's like i'm excited to be part of
something that seems like it's going to
have
you know it's not live service but it's
going to have some legs looks like it's
got some fun
and i think it's going to be a good
package and i hope they do something
like a lords of destruction like dlc
that's my hope it's not planned not
announced nothing in the books but if it
does well i hope it continues
um but for me honestly i'm with you guys
destiny has me
i'm like with teddy i'm a realist like
the cup's not half full or half empty
it's got you know two-thirds cup of
water in it
i'm gonna be a realist at points um but
i it i'm enjoying the story has me
compelled
and i'm just hoping the gameplay
continues to
be enough fun variety and activities to
get me to where hopefully the rpg the
systems the savathun the witch queen
kind of builds what i'm hoping for i'm
hoping that it continues to evolve the
game
in the way that they want and i'm hoping
the story beats continue to be fun along
the way
because i'm hoping witch queen is what
really takes it to
hopefully the next level that's my hope
lots of hope
i think that's the best way for me to
put it um but thank you guys very much
this episode has been an absolute blast
it's a long one editing's gonna be fun
with the clip in the middle but
thanks to all of you guys for being here
thank you chat thank you everybody
teddy travis cog of course a pleasure
everybody
so for today march 19th episode number
141 honestly every time i say one of
those numbers it's crazy it's that high
thank you guys very much but it has been
the last one
all right so i don't have anybody to
raid right now so i'm just gonna wrap up
the stream thank you guys very much
if i do anything tomorrow uh if i get
everything squared away with my dog i
might be streaming hellblade or
something like that so we'll just have
to see
uh but other than that you guys go
follow these gentlemen go support lognet
um
you guys are here but go follow them
they're fantastic so we'll see you guys
soon
thank you chad y'all are amazing have a
good one
all right now finish our audios
all right so you can stop your recording
and then travis i gotta get you the
folder link for this episode so you can
upload it